dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson in your new book
astrophysics for people in a hurry you
open it by saying that the universe is
under no obligation to make sense to you
what does that mean get over it I think
up until well really up to the year 1600
when we didn't have any particular tools
to investigate the natural world our
five senses we're the primary means by
which we obtained all information about
the universe and not even knowing that
our five senses had limits if it's
everything you know you think it's
everything the universe is trying to
give you but in fact it's not and so
around 1600 with the invention of the
microscope in one direction and then the
telescope and the other next direction
each event it within a decade of one
another then all of a sudden pieces of
the universe come available to us that
transcend our senses the fact that
leeuwen hook would look inside of a drop
of pond water and see Mike
microorganisms just like doing the
backstroke right that your your eye
brain sensory system could not have
detected work not for the microscope and
you know you can say does that make
sense that you could have entire living
creatures inside of a drop of water well
today we know that because we learn it
from childhood but in the day it made no
sense at all in fact he had
communication with the Royal Academy
Royal Society in London which is what
you would normally do when you make a
discovery and they thought he was
drinking too much gin it's like good
write another letter when you recovered
from this stupor from this drunken
stupor and that we can continue our
scientific conversation so they were in
denial of it until they send someone up
to verify which is a very natural thing
to happen among scientists one result is
not one eyewitness testimony about one
result is not a scientific discovery you
need verification of it to confirm that
it's real and especially in modern times
the 20th century and onward we have
particle accelerators
we discovered quantum physics which has
rules of how matter behaves that fall
completely outside of not only our
senses but our our our expectations for
how life would or or the how anything
should work particles popping in and out
of existence matter turning into energy
and back and forth so then we discover
like black holes and and the expanding
universe how could everything there is
be expanding at all right and so if you
keep invoking that doesn't make sense
you're going to miss out on a lot of
what we have learnt discovered to be
true about this universe what's
significant about the year 1600 anything
oh well optics had taken it up there's
there's a lot of the Dutch we're very
good at optics and lenses and this sort
of thing and we know about what one lens
would do you can make a little
magnifying glass out of it but sort when
you start combining them you get other
properties of your optical system
enabling you to get a microscope and
once you did that that just opened the
floodgates to what else you would do
when you combine lenses and then Galileo
made a really good version of it back in
the early 1600s and then sky's the limit
as he looked up was Galileo treated as a
kind of a devil in a sense well so it
was a little bit of cleansing so if
depending on how long is the write-up on
the account of his time like in times it
that'll determine how much back you know
background information you'll get so the
the simple story is he makes these
discoveries they conflict with the
teachings of the Catholic Church they
put him on trial they find him guilty of
saying that birth goes around the Sun
and not vice versa as well as other
other discoveries he's made with his
Devils instrument and then they put him
under house arrest what they don't tell
you well they would tell you if you had
a longer biography about him is that he
actually made fun of the Pope public fun
of the Pope he wrote a book in Italian
not in Latin which is the academic
language of the day
in Italian which means the local people
can read it and in it he invents a
conversation between a simpleton and a
someone who is wise of the ways of the
universe and all if you track the
statements of the simpleton they're all
statements that have come but official
decree from the Catholic Church so he's
he's he's really a pompous a-hole
basically can I say that
it was a feast man and so socially he he
did not express the respect he really
should have for people who had much more
power over him he could have published
in Latin had it spread around the world
among academic circles and I'm betting
he probably would not have gone to trial
that's my read of this and then the
period is the Renaissance after all and
you know new thought and fresh thought
was not some weird thing so yeah he was
just he had it coming because he he
didn't know how to appease authority
back to your book astrophysics for
people in hurry 14 billion years ago the
universe started you say how do we know
how do we know that so the way knowledge
is acquired scientifically is you you
have an idea and you propose an
experiment to test the idea and then you
if it's an expensive experiment you
probably don't have the money to do it
in your garage so now you propose to get
funding from sources typically if it's
pure research it'll be a government
source the National Science Foundation
NASA has a research arm if you're in the
other fields like biology human
physiology you might be getting a grant
from the National Institutes of Health
and so so you have this idea you build
an experiment and you test it and if the
results of that experiment match your
expectations then the foundation of your
idea gains some currency in the
conversations you might have at
the scientific coffee lounges at
workshops or in the journals then you're
a competitor of mine and you say you
know I never liked you I have a
different you know huge scientists are
human you know we're people too right so
and I think you're wrong and here's the
experiment I'm going to build to show
that you're wrong so then you build an
experiment and then you get a result it
kind of matches my result that's kind of
that's interesting because you had no no
intent of matching me you don't even
like me
but now the results match and someone
else does it you'll always have some
outliers just because of the
experimental uncertainties that exists
in all experiments will always be some
outlier but when there's a general a
general lean towards a truth and
emergent truth you look back into hell
okay all these experiments pointed
approximately the same result and they
have these few outliers here so now we
come to recognize that this is the new
truth the new objectively established
truth and that's what science does it is
the most effective way we have ever
devised as a species as a culture in
decoding what is and what is not true
about the natural world
nothing rivals it at all and so so once
we've done this then I say here is how
the world works then we go on to the
next problem and this is a celebrated
thing I mean it's what goddess
relativity and quantum physics and
gravity and and it empowered the entire
Industrial Revolution
you couldn't have these machines you
know what is a machine it's something
that converts energy that lives as one
form into energy that's useful to us in
another form so what is a car it takes
chemical energy and gas and turns it
into energy of motion kinetic energy of
your car and that requires machines to
do that all this came out of the
Industrial Revolution before the
Industrial Revolution there were no
there were no machines such as this
there's something they had what we call
simple machines a lever is an ax pulley
those don't require high technology
technically in the world of physics
those are called machines okay a lever a
pulley an inclined plane and what they
do is they make your job a little easier
so it it's simple so what watch how this
works so I have this ledge and I have a
very heavy thing and I want to lift it
up to that ledge well I'm not strong
enough to do that but if I make a ramp
then I can just lift it up little bits
at a time now the distance over which I
have to lift it is longer but it takes
this height and spread that out over
time so that it makes it easier for me
to complete the task the same amount of
total energy is exerted but the rate at
which I expend that energy is different
and that's what that's what simple
machines have always done for us and
modern machines basically empower all of
civilization first ten seconds of the
universe what happen well so that that's
a busy moment inspector oh sorry I
didn't really focus in on your question
about how do we know it's 14 billion
years so here's what we did we look up
in the universe and we say okay we see
galaxies Hubble discovered that these
fuzzy things in the night sky are entire
galaxies such as our Milky Way major
discovery in 1926 and then in 1929 he
discovers that these fuzzy things that
we now identify as whole galaxies are
hurtling away from one another and this
is the first evidence that the universe
is expanding so people just think this
up oh it must be X no it was an
observation and then we look to see if
it fit Einstein's general theory of
relativity and it did general theory of
relativity is the modern understanding
of gravity and if anything's happening
in the universe is going to involve
gravity so you check to see if it works
with this equations it does
and so that way that means we didn't
have to reinvent the theory of the
universe because it worked and so then
we say like if the universe is getting
bigger the universe bigger today than it
was yesterday and that must mean it was
bigger yesterday than it was the day
before and then the day before and then
the day before so what happens if we
just turn the clock back when you do
this because you see how fast we're
expanding just just reverse that you can
do it on a pen sand paper on the back of
an envelope just calculate what happens
if you reverse this rate of expansion
and the whole known universe is in the
same place at the same time fourteen
billion years ago that is the origin of
the idea of the Big Bang
first ten seconds first ten seconds so
everything we know about matter that is
compressed and under pressure tells us
that the temperature will rise and the
simplest example of this is if you ride
a bicycle and your tire gets a little
flat so you pump a hand pump you pump
air into the bicycle tire and then you
feel the valve when you're done it's hot
you are compressing air through it okay
and so that's just an example so it's
related it's not exactly the same thing
but it's related thermodynamically the
science of the movement of energy from
one medium to another is called
thermodynamics so as the universe gets
smaller so on it actually would have
been hotter in the past than it is in
the present and so now you keep because
the inverse actually now has a
temperature you can measure it got
measured in the 1960s very cool you look
in every direction and you see these the
the heat signature left over after the
fourteen billion years and so now you go
back in time
and you say okay the universe was hotter
and hotter and hotter and higher huh how
much hotter would it have been 14
billion years ago when the universe was
this big and you get a stupendously high
temperature and now you ask what is the
behavior of matter and energy under
those temperatures so now you turn to
the particle accelerators that slammed
particles together and the high pressure
high energy high temperature I mean high
so you start approximating the
conditions of the earlier was that what
an atom does is that when a nucleus does
is that what happens so now you take
knowledge gleaned from modern atomic
physics and particle physics and you
apply it to what's going on in the first
few moments of the universe when it was
hot small and dense and that gives you a
pathway in a pathway of insights into
what was going on then you know we find
that you have an area where all
particles are formed the basic
foundational particles that everything
else is comprised of we have light in
the form of photons we have quarks that
make up protons and neutrons we've all
heard of protons and neutrons they're
made of something else
they made it what we call quarks and as
far as we know quarks are fundamental as
far as we know so far
and also electrons and they all have
antimatter counterparts proton electron
has an antenna is called a positron very
cool name actually positron something
that science fiction people rapidly
picked up on just to be clear we
invented antimatter and discovered it
that was not a science fiction invention
although it works great in science
fiction storytelling it happened in the
real universe first so now you you you
put you bring your insights to those
first few moments of the universe and
say what must have happened then given
what we know goes on in our particle
accelerators and it will tell you at the
rate we were expanding at those
temperatures you would be making
hydrogen as the predominant atom in the
universe so simple
adam has only one proton in the nucleus
you make this much hydrogen you make
this much helium that has two protons in
the nucleus
you'll make trace amount of lithium
that's the third element on the periodic
table of elements remember from
chemistry class and nothing else we will
be a universe born with hydrogen and
helium and barely any lithium waving and
you say it's that so it would mean that
the very oldest stars we can find ones
born
closest to the Big Bang that would still
be alive today would be comprised of
only hydrogen and helium that is exactly
what we measure the very oldest stars
have the least amount of heavier
elements which we know we know this from
the mid 20th century from calculations
enabled by the nuclear research from the
Manhattan Project and that the atomic
bomb because we're calculating what
atoms do Weedon we know that after that
time stars are born pure hydrogen and
helium they manufacture heavy elements
in their core then some of them explodes
scattering this enrichment to gas clouds
that have yet to form stars now they
form a next generation of stars that
have a little bit of extra enrichment
they'll make even more enrichment
explode and then carry that extra
enrichment to the next generation and
this continues through we our solar
system was born four-and-a-half billion
years ago so that's more than nine
billion years after the start of the
universe so we've had the benefit of
multiple generations of enrichment so
now an our proto cloud collapsed to make
the Sun it had all these other
ingredients in it that it used to make
planets because rocks are not made of
hydrogen they're not made of helium
they're made of silicon and oxygen and
aluminum
and arsenic all these other Eltham iron
cobalt nickel all of that manufactured
later is in abundance in very late
generation stars that were formed so the
lesson here is how ever weird it is to
assert that 14 billion years ago the
universe was this big literally this big
and exploded from there you say well you
weren't there how do you know okay
you're right I wasn't there but if
everything we know happens to matter
happens then that it accurately predicts
things we do measure that's what give us
gives us the confidence to sit here and
describe the first 10 seconds of the
universe like we were there and it all
started with a big bang huh so a song in
there do we know what that Big Bang loss
do we know what it was yeah all what we
can tell you is that the Big Bang
account of the beginning of the universe
is a description of what matter and
energy was doing from the earliest
moments onwards now there's a there's a
point before which it's a little
mysterious to us it's called the Planck
time named after Max Planck one of the
father many fathers and quantum physics
there's a point earlier in which it's
kind of the limits of our ability to
understand what nature is doing so we
pick it up right after that Planck time
I forgot the exact the Planck time is
like 1 trillion trillionth of a second
after the Big Bang
no trillion 1 billion trillion trillion
was that right 15 1224 yeah that's about
right but well 1 million trillion
trillionth of a second after whatever
was the beginning then our physics that
we now measure in our labs apply and
then we can talk about what's going on
in your book welcome to the universe
from
20:16 you write that in five billion
years the earth will be a charred ember
oh yeah you know it's weird every now
and then I tweet that every couple of
years I tweet that and apparently it
blows people's minds and I don't know if
that's a good thing or a bad thing
but so the tweet goes it varies any time
I do but it goes something like this in
five billion years the Sun will expand
so large that it will engulf the entire
orbit of our planet as we double Gulf
the entire it will engulf earth as Earth
and earth will be a charred ember as it
descends into this star while it
vaporizes have a nice day
or something like that and people so if
it's just a reality and it's a
remarkable that we can know our fate in
that way over that much time but how do
we know it will we be there probably not
so how do we know what there are other
stars there's no shortage of stars in
the universe we can see stars being born
we see stars living out their lives we
see stars in the act of dying and you
can staple these bits of information
together and create a coherent story in
other words we don't live long enough to
see a star born live out its life and
die it takes millions and sometimes
billions and in some cases trillions of
years and we're around for a few decades
so how is it that we know this because
there are so many stars that in any
snapshot of the universe we see stars
being born stars and in middle-aged
stars dying and we look to see oh these
are the steps the same arc of a star
they're just different stars with what
we're catching at a different time it
wouldn't be any different from if you
were an alien took a snapshot of
civilization you would see some humans
in a box underground
so what are they doing there you see
other humans who are like little things
crawling on the carpet you'll see other
humans who are who don't have any hair
that a little and others that don't have
any hair who are older right it's just a
snapshot because you don't you don't
live long enough to see the whole thing
if you're an alien and you live just 90
seconds it alright so you'll say how do
I make sense out of this are people born
in a box in the ground and they're all
shriveling and then they come out of the
box and then they get littler and
littler and littler and then disappear
inside of another person or is it the
opposite so you keep studying all these
photos that you have and then you can
piece together a coherent story of
what's going on
and for the stars in the universe this
took decades we did just look at one
synapse Donatello that bigs born there
and dies this know this took effort this
was major telescopes being brought to
bear a lot of human capital intellectual
capital invested in trying to understand
what stars are and how them and why they
work a lot of this traces back to the
Harvard College Observatory in Cambridge
Massachusetts with there's a room full
of than computers these are human
calculators computers and all women
because that was judged to be menial
work and the men stayed in their offices
you know doing high-level thinking and
in this in this room of women was the
foundation of our understanding of
stellar evolution and a Dabba soul you
should get her on this just wrote a book
on this I think we called the glass
universe I think you've covered it yeah
yeah just as a as an homage to the glass
ceiling the glass universe little did
the high and mighty men know that when
you calculate data that was collected
from all the world's telescopes on
stars therein was the source of the
seeds of how and why stars are born live
out their lives and die and this is book
TV on c-span 2 this is our monthly
in-depth program and this month we have
author and astrophysicist Neil deGrasse
Tyson is our guest as you know if you
watch this program we spend three hours
with one author talking about his or her
body of work and this month
it's dr. Tyson beginning in 1989 dr.
Tyson has written several books
merlyn's tour of the universe was his
first universe down to earth came out in
1994 just visiting this planet 1998 the
sky is not the limit that was his fourth
book 2001 universe also came out in 2000
and then cosmic horizons came out in
2001 origins came out in 2004 death by
black hole 2007 the Pluto files 2009
Space Chronicles three years later and
then last year Startalk came out as well
as welcome to the universe and his most
recent book astrophysics for people in a
hurry if you'd like to participate in
our program this afternoon here's how
you can do so we'll put the phone
numbers up to zero to is area code seven
four eight eighty two hundred for those
of you in the East and Central time
zones seven four eight eight two zero
one if you live in the mountain and
Pacific time zones go ahead and start
dialing in now if you can't get through
on the phone lines still want to ask a
question or participate in our program
try us on social media at book TV is our
twitter handle you can also make a
comment on our Facebook page you'll see
dr. Tyson's picture there just make a
comment right underneath facebook.com
slash book TV and finally email book TV
at c-span org and we'll begin taking
those in just a few minutes dr. Tyson
back to your most recent book
astrophysics for people in a hurry forty
billion earth-like planets in the Milky
Way alone I've got two questions what is
the Milky Way
how big a space are we talking about
forty billion earth-like planets yeah so
I it was hard-earned to learn what the
Milky Way was consider that term that we
use dates from ancient Rome Rome when
they built streets they didn't call them
streets they call them ways the Appian
Way for example you look up in the night
sky and see this Milky band of light and
they just called the Milky Way the milky
Street literally and in China where milk
is a less popular beverage into
adulthood they don't call it the Milky
Way they call it the silver River and so
this is a well-known feature in the
night sky imagine to just be some cloud
of light crossing from one horizon to
the next and it would not be until
Galileo and other large telescopes
brought to bear on this question did we
learn that when you put a telescope on
the Milky band of light it reveals
itself into stars
countless stars that without a telescope
are just so far away the light sort of
puddles together so we say Wow
alright but is this all there is just
stars in front of our face and then the
stars that are far away that make this
band it would be it would take until
1920 before we resolve the debate about
whether the spiral fuzzy things in the
night sky were actual other galaxies
separate from our Milky Way that got
resolved very quickly after 1920 and
especially with Hubble's observation
that there other that these are other
entire galaxies beyond the Milky Way and
so there's we now know there's nearly a
hundred billion galaxies in the
observable universe and each galaxy has
hundreds of billions of stars on average
and so there's a range big galaxies
little galaxies but we count them up 100
billion stars per galaxy 100 billion
galaxies
and there you have the observable
universe and these are scattered
throughout the landscape like cities
dotting a countryside when viewed from
space the local areas of light you've
mentioned him a couple times Edwin
Hubble who was he well so there's a
telescope of course after whom I had
been Hubble the telescope was named
after Edwin Hubble he was a bit of a
pompous kind of snooty astrophysicist
back in the early part of the 20th
century he did his best work in the
1920s he had access to the biggest
telescope so that always leaves open the
question would anybody with access to
the world's biggest telescope be making
the world's greatest discoveries or does
it also require some kind of insight to
empower you to even know what question
to ask so for him is probably a
combination of both but he stories about
him he wear these sort of tweed suits
and smoked a pipe and done a partly
British accent when he's from like from
backwoods America so but anyhow doesn't
get a good thing about science you your
personality is completely irrelevant to
the quality of the work that comes out
of your lab and so you can pray
someone's work without that having to be
being praiseworthy or the person
themselves you can just separate the two
so he worked for the Carnegie
observatories in California and yeah I
think back then if they if they figured
out that they should have they would
have given him a Nobel Prize for these
discoveries but astronomer types didn't
start getting a Nobel Prize until the
1960s so it would be the Nobel Prize in
Physics given to an astrophysicist so we
get them maybe once a decade or so for
something we do you use this example in
astrophysics for people in a hurry you
talk about the earth as an apple and
then the skin of the Apple is
basically where we've traveled in a
sense and I'm probably getting it a
little wrong oh yeah so now I can
tighten that up so people we think to
ourselves that here you are walking
around on the surface of a planet and
we're at the bottom of this ocean of
atmosphere okay whereas the thickness of
the functional thickness of our
atmosphere is to the size of the earth
what the skin of an apple is to an apple
what the shellac is to a school room
globe that's on that school room globe
so this atmosphere is not some infinite
extent of air molecules it is it is a
fragile thin skin on this thing we call
Earth and I can quantify this for you
the atmosphere has particles associated
with it they go up thousands of miles
but the part that when I said it's
functional thickness because there's not
an edge not atmosphere on this side not
on that's a no-no it fades but you can
say what distance so in the daytime how
come you can't see stars you can ask
that question and you said well because
the Sun is out no that's not why you
can't see stars but could the Sun of
that you can't see stars because we have
an atmosphere and the atmosphere
scatters sunlight rendering itself aglow
so in the daytime our atmosphere glows
sky blue and that prevents you from
seeing the stars in the daytime sky if
you go to the moon you can be in broad
daylight but there is no atmosphere you
look away from the Sun have your eyes
adapt there's the full nighttime sky so
you can ask the question what altitude
above the earth do you have to travel
before the atmosphere is so thin that
you can see stars in the daytime that's
100 kilometers up about 62 miles and so
that's the functional definition that we
invoke about being in space
and that's 62 miles is what is the skin
of an apple - an apple as is our
atmosphere - the size of our planet
how far out have we gotten from Mir do
we go for the roof
well with satellites or anything Oh much
farther okay but humans we've gone to
the far side of the moon when the moon
was the moon's orbit around the earth is
not a perfect circle so sometimes it's
farther it's like an ellipse so Apollo 8
was an Apollo 13
it was Apollo 13 went to the moon when
the moon was it nearest farthest point
from the earth and they went around the
moon before they made their trajectory
landed they wanted to but they had
remembered they had the the oxygen tank
got destroyed so on the backside of the
moon in that trajectory they were the
farthest humans had ever been from Earth
and so how far that about 240,000 miles
away so in terms of spacecraft we the
Voyager spacecraft just a few years ago
launched in 1977 given some gravity
boosts but slingshotting around Jupiter
and Saturn and and I forgot the exact
comic it was multiple planet multi
cushion pool shot to exploit the the
orbital energy of these various planets
because we couldn't launch it with
enough energy to escape the solar system
it had to be it had to steal energy from
planets in order to make this happen and
we did this quite on purpose so you do
this that Voyager 1 has now basically
left all traces of the solar system so
it's doesn't being going just past
Neptune the last planet in the solar
system if there's like comets beyond
that the Kuiper belt of comets of which
pluto is a happy member there's you go
beyond and beyond the beyond and you
reach a point where the sun's influence
on the electronics of your spacecraft
are now confused
is with the influence of everything else
in the galaxy and that's a functional
place to say you have left the solar
system and Voyager has done just that
and that far away oh I forgot the number
several hundred times the Earth's Sun
distance but I forgot to I have to look
that number up but it's far it's the
farthest anything is out there still
producing well yeah but you have to ask
if we're still learning anything and
what is them you know it's cost money to
always keep something on line and we
keep talking to it and which by the way
we go through these funding episodes
often you have something that's kind of
working but it's exhausted it's useful
life but it's still taking money so you
shut this off and then get a fresh
project then we'll have new questions
that you're answering would you keep
this going because you know it still
works and you might discover something
so we have what are called senior
reviews each year
where some of the most respected among
us get together and decide what switch
gets turned off and what switch gets
turned on and that's why it's important
that it's our most respected scientist
among us because then we we judge that
they are being fair in these assessments
so so the Voyager spacecraft farthest
thing we've ever sent by the way at the
rate which is traveling if you aimed it
to the nearest star it would take
seventy thousand years to get there so
give up all expectations that we're
going to be visiting other planets
outside of our solar system anytime soon
1973 how'd you end up in the Mojave
Desert oh yeah 73 uh so I attended a
camp a special astronomy camp for like
geeky school kids I was in 73 yeah I was
in ninth grade yeah so that was my first
year in high school because back then
what they called sorry I was
transitioning from ninth grade to 10th
grade and ninth grade was the oldest
grade in my junior high school today
they called up middle schools and they
ended eighth grade but anyhow
so that I was transitioning between the
two I was a geeky kid as well as every
other kid at this camp we lived in the
Mojave Desert far away from any lifes
very low atmospheric humidity which is
one of the definitions of a desert and
so that means there's no cloud formation
very few clouds and we all live
nocturnally and you wake up at night and
there's a whole slew of telescopes we
all had research projects and computers
were very early at the time as we're
programming this week route hovered
around this computer we all try to
program it one of us programmed it to
spew out prime numbers which is a
interative calculation we made it do ya
this event this early this is like
computation BCE so those are some
formative years of my life ninth grade
tenth grade 11th grade transitioning out
of middle school into high school I
attended the Bronx High School of
Science the borough that I grew up in
and I had a telescope and the camera and
so yeah I was just that that that was a
happy summer and my mother as a city kid
that was my first time in the desert and
then all these like creatures at night
there was like you know tarantulas and
black widows and not tarantulas black
widows and what's the motive scorpions
they said don't put your foot in your
boot until you shake out the blue
otherwise you'll get venom injected into
your it's like hook heavy back to the
city where my only all I thought just
might be mugged that's all
at least least I could talk to the
mugger you know so but it was it was it
was fun it was fun and so my mother saw
an ad for this camp and she knew that I
was had been interested in the universe
for the previous five years of my life
and then she was why would I know where
to look for an ad or even have that as
an ambition so my parents were
particularly sensitive to what the
interests
were me my brother and my sister so they
didn't impart interest upon us they
carefully observed where we expressed
interest and then fed those interests in
whatever way best served our curiosity
now with Cyril and sanchita yeah yes sir
Oh Tyson sanchita Tyson I just lost my
father this past into 7 December yeah
yeah he's 89 so there's a full life I
still miss him he ends up he was wise
wise man and I think in modern times we
forget what wisdom is you know there
people who know a lot and they talk a
lot and their pundits and and wise
people don't talk a lot they do more
observing than talking and then
somewhere in their head mixed with their
life experience they digest it and then
come out with with simple
easy-to-understand perspective that then
sort of live with you course they'll
live with you because they're the
digestion of so many different pieces
that you didn't necessarily have access
to but they did because they live longer
than you and they're observant their
whole lives 2012 your book space
chronicles came out and in that book on
page 234 you write that our nation is
turning into an idiocracy that was I
that harsh awful up page that's why I
wrote the page number just in case you a
question that you wrote that I yeah okay
sure
I'm normally softer with my critiques
than that normally the way I would
present such a statement would be we are
behaving this way in these situations if
that continues we would then become a
nation in idiocracy that's generally how
I word that so I would double check
after a 301 when the cameras fell off on
the right now so I think if if people
don't or they stopped valuing disco
three so just just just for as backdrop
for space chronicles facing the ultimate
frontier if I can just tell a brief
backstory to that we've got three hours
so I'm assuming I could ultimately maybe
how I worded all that okay
our nation is turning pretty and
regionally okay okay so you've got a
getting this quote it's verbatim
so thank you so an idiocy in the context
in which I've discussed it um it's not a
system where people simply don't know
things okay if you don't know something
there's no crime in that maybe you
didn't study it maybe you didn't spend
sixteen years in school and he spent
only 12 over 20 years in school as some
people do to get advanced degrees so as
an educator I will never hold someone's
absence of knowledge against it the
problem arises if you have an absence of
knowledge and you either know or worse
don't know that you have this absence of
knowledge and then you have power over
legislation that should be informed by
that knowledge and is not and then you
have you come to it aggressively in your
ignorance that is that as a recipe for
societal disaster so part of what it is
to be educated is to have a keen sense
of when you don't know something and you
either do the homework yourself you know
just because you're not in school
doesn't mean you can or shouldn't do
homework all right just because you're
not at school doesn't mean you shouldn't
keep learning so that's an obvious point
so the viewers of book TV of course but
in the for the general population
consider how many people you know who
might have run down the steps on the
last day of school and
thrown their notes in the air school
down whether that's the last day of
school because they're graduating even
just any other year up until graduation
summer I don't have to learn anymore and
where does that come from how is it that
your time in school can lead you to
celebrate being out of school what's
that about what is what is missing in
the educational pipeline that people
resent being in school what is missing
where in college you attend a lecture
but the word lecture outside of college
is otherwise a bad word stop lecturing
me I don't want to be lectured that it's
a bad work what's going on so so maybe
what we're missing in the educational
system isn't is a is a a reminder that
can be fun to learn and the last day of
school people should walk down the steps
sad that now there's an entire summer
where they won't be learning what a
world that would be oh my gosh so do we
teach it differently are we selecting
our teachers the white right way or the
curriculum I don't I don't have an
answer for that and simply simply
sharing the observation and I know
that's not helpful to just point it out
but I would claim a lot of the world's
problems would be solved if education
became a joyous experience rather than
it's something you want to escape from
as quickly as possible so an idiocracy
of course I draw that word from the film
it was an indie film called idiocracy if
you might build an Netflix it or
something but it was a world where the
people in charge did not fully
understand the decision the consequences
of the decisions they were making and
the absence of understanding came from
an absence of awareness of how nature
works
and there's a scene where they're
feeding Gatorade to plants because the
ads for Gatorade said it replenishes
your nutrients so they said well if it
works for us I bet it works for our
plants they just poured maybe just it he
just got to see official government
decisions that had little or no anchor
in reality yet everyone kind of thought
it was the right thing to do so I so so
so in in space chronicles facing the
ultimate frontier it contains an
exploration of all the elements of
society that might not be in a position
to judge or make an informed decision
about the value of space exploration
going forward and that was in 2012 just
recently in The Wall Street Journal an
article by an op-ed by Crispin Sartre
well this is a quote in the Trump era
says celebrity physicists Neil deGrasse
Tyson who adds that this is the most
important thing he's ever said people
quote have lost the ability to judge
what is true and what is not okay so
that sentence that was from a video that
was posted just before the science March
that sentence did not include reference
to Trump at all that was added in that
editorial I just said we live in a time
where people have lost the ability to
judge what is true and what is not and
if you want to call the pre-election
Eric part of a Trump era okay but if
you're looking at something on the
internet and you think it's true and do
not have the capacity to judge whether
it's not true
that is another element that is another
ingredient in the recipe for disaster so
this is this Trump is a manifestation
the Trump era where what is true and
what is not has is home
and we're almost that distinction is not
made where that is risen to high Heights
I would claim those seeds that those
seeds were germinating long before and
it has to do with what people think is
true after they read it on the internet
our susceptibility to this and here's
something else again I hate to sound
like a broken record if anyone remembers
what a broken record is that in k-12
somewhere in there
rather than pouring knowledge into
people's heads and declaring them to be
educated for having done so somewhere in
there we need to train people how to
think how to analyze how to interpret
how to be skeptical of information and
then how to recognize when sufficient
data has been put for us to turn
something that you might be skeptical
about into something that is a newly
established objective truth that is not
taught in the schools this should be a
class just on what science is and how
and why it works and that would
transcend the physics class the
chemistry class the biology class the
geology class the general science class
this would be its own course so that
when you are college educated and some
institution has declared you graduated
and alerted member of society if you
turn around and say I choose not to
believe this emergent scientific
consensus I know you don't have that
option
it's not how objectively established
scientific truths are determined it is
true whether or not you believe in it
and in retrospect you think maybe that's
what you should base legislation on not
something you want to be true or feel
should be true or it's something that
you that that you don't allow to be true
because your religion prevents it or
because your political philosophy
prevents it you don't have that option
if it's an objectively established truth
and like I said earlier that is the
entire point of the scientific
enterprise knowing what is true what is
not and in particular
just like I said scientists are humans
too and we have bias and we have all the
stuff that goes on but every other human
in this world also touches scientists so
we built a system to double-check
against that if I am biased and my bias
shows up in some result because I took
some data and not others and I could
have done it this way and not somebody
else is gonna get famous for checking my
result and showing that I'm wrong
Dyson is wrong he messed up here and if
it's shown that I that my bias did
influence it I get a demerit that's not
a real thing but it's there it's it will
it will interfere with the next time I
have an interesting result and I want
people to pay attention to it so there's
a huge cost if a scientist is somehow
meddling with their data because they
have an idea of what they want their
data to show then it comes at a huge
cost to their career but even if they
think they can get away with it somebody
else will ultimately find it and if they
show that it's wrong then we don't have
any result at all and your bet everybody
is back to the drawing board so so
objective truth I'm thinking that's what
any law legislation should be based on
if you base it on anything else then you
are imposing what might be your personal
truth your political your personal truth
is everyone should fend for themselves
and not get a government handout let's
say that's your you feel really strongly
about that well that's how you feel and
in a free country
go right ahead if you want everyone else
to feel that that's politics fine go
have that political discussion in the
floor of Congress because that will
affect where monies go
the a--fun this support program do you
not do you put in a tariff do you
subsidize do you not that's a political
conversation go right ahead and then the
law that comes out
have political flavor to it I don't have
a problem as that but if your law
somehow pivots on something that is not
scientifically true you're building a
house of cards with a first flute or
first two floors look stable but they're
completely Hollow and empty by the time
you put on a third floor the whole thing
collapses nature is the ultimate judge
jury and executioner
of what is true space Chronicles 2012 we
need to go back to the moon I I will not
say what we need to do all I will do
because I'm not I'm not a pundit trying
to get everyone to agree with an opinion
I might have what I do instead of other
space Chronicles is a collection of
everything I've ever thought and written
on space exploration and so it contains
like op-eds and articles and speeches
it's a it's an amalgam and so you can
dip it's very easy to dip in and out of
but I'm not going to tell you we should
go to the moon know what I'm going to
say is that high highly ambitious
exercises conducted by governments have
huge exhibit huge force on the ambitions
of a nation on the creativity of the
nation on the innovations of the nation
I don't think it's an accident that
Steve Jobs and Bill Gates were 12 and 14
what if somewhere around there when we
landed on the moon how impressionable
can you be can you get there it is
there's a future that and you see this
and you don't even have to be interested
in space you just have to be interested
in the fact that new frontiers are being
breached and it's possible to do so and
then it gets infused into your into your
goals into your it into your trajectory
of life so I'm offering space
exploration be at the
moon Mars beyond doesn't matter but if
you go into space it is adventurous it
is you have to invent stuff to make that
if you're advancing a frontier you're
gonna have to invent some because you
can't just use off-the-shelf things
you're going to have to use and invent
things that have never been used or
invented before that takes ingenuity
innovation clever engineers scientists
working together and you might even need
clever lawyers why because oh I want to
live on the moon who owns that plot of
moon surface is it am I in my
homesteading a my I want to mine an
asteroid for natural resources who owns
the asteroid should anyone on the
asteroid these are legal questions
that's a whole legal frontier so
everyone can become a participant in
this and when that happens the
government does it first because the
government doesn't have to satisfy a
quarterly report the government can open
new industries as it's done before as it
did with aviation the government monies
from the government prompted innovations
in aviation in its earliest days because
I'm saying I owe an airplane now we can
carry mail through the air who wants the
contract and each I want the contract I
can carry four bags of mail and somebody
else is I'm using the same plane as you
but I can make a modification I can make
the hole a little bigger I can carry a
little more fuel make sure I can carry
six magazine a mail and so there is a
race to see who would then get these
government contracts to carry air mail
and what if so what happens the fifth
person says I can carry 30 bags and
whatever make up these numbers what the
sense of it is correct at 30 bags
minutes of wait a minute I don't need to
carry mail I just put champions now I
can sell seats and then vests is born an
entire industry of aviation because of
certain investments that a government
makes that then enable subsequent
entrepreneurs
to expect the new place that the
technology has been taken so we go into
space I'd say you have a whole suite of
launch vehicles and where do you want to
go today are you on a mine an asteroid
that's why I put these two Rockets
together and you bring all your own
equipment because I don't know how to
dig on an asteroid but you'll know there
you go oh you're a biologist you want to
look for life on the surface of Mars
strap these together there's a big
pocket in this and if foods there you go
we want to torse jaunt around the moon
that's these rockets and all of a sudden
the solar system becomes our backyard
again to do all this requires huge
levels of innovation but I would claim
that once there's a first round of
innovation that can establish the cost
and the risks and the returns on
investment then private enterprise comes
in and then they do they do their thing
as they always do no different from the
Dutch East India Trading Company coming
in after Christopher Columbus who
himself was sent by Spain and he comes
back and says we're how long it took you
quantify things the thing you can make a
business case to to exploit if you can
find another way to infuse an entire
nation well with ambitions of tomorrow
that will trigger innovations of today
thereby assuring a future of health
wealth and security because that's
coming from technology it's not coming
from any other branch of human existence
but science and technology are going to
give us tomorrow's health wealth and
security I'm simply offering the
exploration of the universe as a force
of nature operating on our innovations
on our urge to innovate if you have
something else bring it in I'm not going
to if it works and it works better go
ahead I've yet to hear of a better
example another quote from space
Chronicles NASA operates on our hearts
on our minds on the educational pipeline
all for one half cent on the tax dollar
about a twenty dollar twenty billion
dollar yes if you just take twenty
billion and divide it by by the the
budget
I forgot what is it three trillion four
trillion whatever the number is if you
if you run the numbers it comes in to
about a half a penny on the tax dollar
and if you hold up in a literal dollar
and then take scissors and cut one half
of one percent of its width you don't
even get into the ink from the side of
the dollar and when people say buy wise
mess is spending those money up there
when we have problems here on earth and
that's assuming that if you took all the
money we spent on NASA and then apply
them to the problems in the earth that
all the problems would get solved that
very statement kind of presupposes that
yet most of those people who utter that
sentence do not actually know how much
NASA is getting I've done I've done this
I've done it like people on the street
right so you ask the people who complain
about NASA I say well here's a tax law
how much do you think they're gay Oh 10%
15% 5%
no one-half of 1% when I tell them that
I didn't know that is that half of 1%
they made a space station and the space
shuttles and the Hubble telescope and
all the NASA centers and the Cassini
mission which is now at at Saturn all of
this is in the one half of one percent
on a tax dollar so I asked you I posed
the question to you how much is the
universe worth to you all right one more
observation and then we're going to take
your calls you've been very patient
we've spoken for an hour now we've got
two hours to take his to take calls and
and hear from dr. Tyson first I want to
show this and I'm not getting it right
there are four books you have here the
Pluto files death by black hole space
Chronicles and origins what's special
about these world books they did this
and I was very impressed that your
publisher
yeah the publisher Norton so these four
different books and they all have
different covers okay
very kind of Spacey covers as you as you
might expect because all the books are
on the universe and so I they decided to
make the bindings match up into a
coherent I just came in so this is the
famous ring nebula if you can see Letty
Griffith if you just take it I gotta get
there we go
but that aha
so it's the ring nebula as what it's a
fact it's a it's the death throes of a
star our Sun will look something like
that
so in the center this is the remains of
a star that once was and its outer
layers expanded into oblivion and so now
these have expanded hugely much bigger
than what is the extent of our orbiting
planets and so they're tons of these in
the night sky that's how we know how
stars died this is one way this is a non
explosive death we have examples of
explosive deaths and they're much than
much Rati er they're much courrier
it really looks like stellar guts spewed
forth whereas this is rather stately and
beautiful like a smoke ring so yes and I
have to get all four books by which I
couldn't undo well let's begin with a
question via email this is from a young
man named Bradley Nitin his parents both
work at c-span long time Dave and April
both work at c-span for a long time did
you give them preference to get their
question first well you know what I
might have gotten an email that's
directly yes and this is from April and
she says my son Bradley who's 11 as a
question for dr. Tyson here's a question
when going to a different planet what
aspect of traveling will be most
important so the great question is a lot
of thinking about this especially at the
Johnson Space Center in Houston
NASA's headquarters for sort of the
manned spaceflight
it's not called crewed crw crude
spaceflight so they worry about food not
only is there enough food but will you
like the food
if you get bored with the food will that
affect your morale and then you're less
effective doing other tasks do you need
comfort food do you want exotic food
international food the water supply is
there enough water do you recycle the
water if you recycle the water that
means it collects all of your urine
filters it and then you drink it back is
that too freaky for you to do is that
should way water is not uncommon in the
universe but in space is hard to get to
you got to like last soo a comment if
you want to hold supply of fresh water
and we don't know how to do that other
things the time in a close quarters with
only one or two or three other people
months and months and in some cases
years there's a whole psychological
dimension to that can we remain
emotionally stable over those times on
earth people kill one another they get
into fights they there many even in the
film interstellar there's an astronaut
fight scene which was like water that
but nonetheless they showed it and of
course there's two guys and astronaut
students fighting on an alien planet so
so there's that there's will they miss
their family or their loved ones at home
there's the fact that if you fly without
creating artificial gravity that you are
weightless the whole time are you
perpetually motion sick or do you get
used to it and if you get used to it are
there any other factors on the body your
body expects one gravity one 1g we call
it which is the equivalent of Earth's
surface gravity and if you go to
centrifuge that you can increase the
gravity with a centrifuge but through
space if you can create artificial
gravity good if you can't what does it
like to be weightless for a year on
route to your destination or longer we
already know some of the answers to that
you begin to lose bone density you have
the bones of a frail old woman if you
keep this up so we have to figure out
what exercise
is will will give you the kind of
resistance that we live in moving
against gravity I reach for this cup I
have to lift it against gravity and
little things that we take for granted
are not something that is normal when
you were in space so all of these
factors have to come together and which
is why you can't just send any old
person into space they have to be
healthy he also wanted to be competent
in performing tasks and you might want
to throw in a medical doctor if the crew
is large enough because something might
happen to you physiologically and then
you need some engineers you need the
combination of expertise so that the
collective safety of the crew is
preserved so all of this matters and
there's another book I can recommend by
Mary Roach it's called packing for Mars
where all the little little little
things you've got to keep track of we
interviewed her for star talk and
there's a whole section in the star talk
book which you didn't you didn't bring
today I went through it but it was too
heavy to bring to hands in heavy debris
dad's gravity I'm sorry the universe has
some weight all right we got to do this
in zero-g next time then you'll have no
excuse they can just toss the book and
it'll float into your BLAP
so yeah great question Thanks and Mary
Roach has been on this program you can
go to book TV Norg you can watch the
three hours with author Mary Roach as
well well Bernie and Howard Beach New
York you have been very patient you are
on with Neil deGrasse Tyson
thank you it's a it's a pleasure to
listen to mr. Tyson I have a couple of
questions first does the Big Bang
violate the conservation of energy could
it be that we're going to have a big
crunch followed by another big bang
followed by another big crunch ad
infinitum and I'd love to see you run
for Congress I send the Tyson sounds
really good to me thank you
Vernie why why have you thought about
this Big Bang do you work in some kind
of scientific field er just took some
physics while I was in school
and the the Big Bang especially is
interesting because it's almost a
religious question I I think that it's
still possible that you can make a case
for the universe to have been here all
the time forever but originally there
was something like a steady state theory
which was abolished by the Big Bang but
it doesn't seem to preclude the idea
that the universe was always here and if
the universe was always here well then
we don't need a creator doing thank you
that's Bernie and Howard beats New York
okay I think I have mental record of
each one of those in sequence so a a
couple of things first all evidence we
have ever obtained in the history of
this exercise in since the beginnings of
cosmology which basically came to us
with Einstein and Edwin Hubble and
others that gave supportive data for
this and it includes a Belgian priest
even by the name of George LaMotta who
was generally considered the father
literal and figurative father of the Big
Bang itself he wrote down the equations
using Einsteins new theory of gravity to
show that we would have a beginning in
the past so so so all data we have ever
obtained is unequivocal in its
conclusion that we are on a one-way
expansion trip one way so so no crunch
no crunch no slowdown stop and then Rica
laughs not that it reca lapse is
prohibited by Einstein E and gravity or
by any other sense of what the universe
could do we happen to be a universe
where that is not the case so this is
simple
now given that it's only a one-way trip
that means we had a beginning and the
entire Big Bang description takes us
from the beginning into the unlimited
future so you might then ask and I'm
putting these words in the question in
his mouth but it gets to his other
question what was around before the
beginning well we don't have data for
that so we don't know but we've got top
people working on it and one of the
ideas which actually comes naturally out
of the extensions of Einstein's gravity
and the extensions of quantum physics is
that there may have been a multiverse
and a multiverse would then pre-exists
our universe we're just a bubble that
came out of it among possibly infinite
other bubbles so these are other
universes with slightly different laws
of physics manifest within them and so
so just to imagine that the universe was
always there not our universe because we
had a beginning but maybe the multiverse
was always there that's possible oh
maybe the multiverse had a beginning
maybe the multiverse is one expression
of what a Metaverse creates look I mean
if there's a Metaverse that each has
bubbles of multiverses in each of
multiverse creates universes ah is there
anything to prevent that in principle no
and that philosophical trajectory is not
fundamentally different from thinking
earth as if it is it oh no no we're one
of eight planets get over it ah then so
that it's a demotion then we say well
how about the Sun Sun of course now the
Sun is just one of a hundred billion
other Suns in the Milky Way the Milky
Way of course no it's one of a hundred
billion other galaxies so we've had good
precedent for recognizing that the
universe is really bad at making things
in one's and that may be true even for
the universe itself that there could
simply be multiple universes
and I think that may have been two out
of three of the of his questions you
will keep keeping notes here there was a
he asked you know and you talk about
this and several of your your books and
your talks is their religious aspect to
the Big Bang Theory and then he have you
ever considered running for office oh
thank you
oh so so the thing is when you use the
word religion it comes with certain
expectations of what it means and here
in the West what most places of the
world when you say religion
it involves a a document of some kind a
holy God holy book that prescribes what
you should believe even in the absence
of evidence and it then tells you about
what conduct you should have in the in
the in the fact of that belief system
okay in science you can put forth an
idea that doesn't yet have evidence but
everybody's looking for evidence and if
we cannot generate evidence for it then
it ultimately would just simply be
discarded and put on a shelf so evidence
matters in this so if you want to call
it a religion with evidence okay that's
just a very fresh usage of the word
religion in your vocabulary so I don't I
don't debate words with people that's I
don't I don't value time invested in
debating definitions just tell me how
you're using the word and I'll tell you
whether what it is agrees with it if
using the word religion in a way that
allows evidence to define what it is
people think say and do then fine it's
all religion because that's what science
does it finds evidence that defines and
discovers the truth of the world that's
just not simply how anybody else in the
world is using the word religion these
need to refer to some kind of spiritual
elements that require faith in something
being true rather than evidence for
something being true political office oh
I was once asked by the New York Times
there was some impasse
several impasses ago in Congress and
they just thought they would have fun
and ask people who are definitely not
politicians what solutions do they have
for getting things through Congress and
fixing things and I think the way they
asked it was but if you were president
what would you do what solutions do you
have so I wrote back if I were president
I wouldn't be president you can find
it's on my website you say if I were
president you just Google that in my
name Tyson it'll take you to the near my
take into the New York Times part but I
duplicated it in my website because they
cut out a paragraph that there's not
enough space so the full response to
that question is there and it comes down
to the expectation that if you run for
office you somehow can change everything
and I'm not convinced of that so I'm a
little contrarian here in fact my views
would be but the literal opposite of
what a lobbyist does lobbies go straight
to the politician to influence the
politician in ways that serve the
interest of the lobbyists and who they
represent for me any elected official
represents people who put them into
office so as an educator what matters is
not so much who the official is what
matters is what is the state of
enlightenment of who's doing the voting
because if people for example all knew
recognized and valued what science is
and how and why it works they would
never even dream of voting for someone
who doesn't know that because that
person would then not represent their
full interests so I would rather educate
an electorate so they can put people in
office who can make scientifically
informed decisions about everything they
do rather than just install myself into
office and lead people who don't yet
have this knowledge or insight that's
not what and
eighty-eight thing I did the math right
on this 88% of Congress stands for
re-election every two years so you can
convince one congressman or another but
then you got to start all over again you
educate the electorate we're good I go
to the Bahamas elect people will take
this country into the future rather than
back into the cave next call for Neil
deGrasse Tyson comes from David in East
Hampton Massachusetts
good afternoon David hi another family
member of mine I was telling him that
you were on TV and suggesting he might
want to watch and he told me something
that he heard I don't know how accurate
this is or what the story is but
basically he said something about
something called an EM Drive that
supposedly can drive a spaceship quickly
and I'm just wondering is an EM Drive a
real thing and if so what is it and how
does it work
and also I'd be interested to hear about
other possible drives for spaceships for
long distance travel like to Mars or
even further yes that's a great question
let me just give some backstory so right
now our rocket ships are we're still
using just little called chemical energy
so you have some molecule which when you
break it apart it releases energy so in
chemistry we say it's exothermic as
opposed to endothermic where the
reaction absorbs energy and by the way
we we experience this if you ever see
cold packs that you buy in a drugstore
where you sort of squeeze it and then
the think it just gets cold well that's
an endothermic reaction is sucking
energy out from its environment and then
you have heat packs where the opposite
happens so you can get very clever with
your chemistry and make this happen
well rockin in his or endothermic so you
squeeze the rocket and then look so it's
highly exothermic what a rocket engine
does so but we've had chemical fuel
since since Robert Goddard back in when
his experiments early 1920s or so so
very little hasn't
proved in our capacity to propel
ourselves through space since you know
for a hundred years almost now so
there's been some talk about other kinds
of drives the one of them is a solar
sail where you can use propulsion from
sunlight that you open up a huge sail
relative to the size of your craft so
that you get maximum sort of pressure
from sunlight and that can accelerate
you and accelerate you for free and with
the way you move around as you attack
just the way you would a sail boat you
would tack into the wind or away from
the wind or but fit nap but here the
wind is sunlight that you're doing this
with and that you can navigate the solar
system it's a little slower but maybe
you would ship cargo that way and then
send people faster and so the future of
space exploration need not be limited to
chemical energy there are other drives
there's a there's a plasma drive where
you have very hot gas and you let very
highly high-speed particles come out
because the hot air gas is the faster
the particles move and you let them come
out and that is a very low impulse
propulsion but it's very high so no
you're not going to sort of accelerate
very much when one particle comes out
but this accumulates and you can
ultimately accelerate to very high
speeds doing so now so here's the
problems this and the M drive and all of
these frontier means of propulsion yeah
you can go real fast with them instead
of taking nine months to get to Mars
you'll take a month okay perhaps if you
want to go to visit Saturn instead of
taking twenty years you'll take two
years but even if you got to the speed
of light near the speed of light it's
not going to reach the speed of light
near the speed of light you want to
cross the galaxy we'll watch you do this
by our time reckon you'll take you a
hundred thousand years to cross they get
at the speed of light
so the the answer here by the way you
will age much more slowly so you'll get
there without much time having elapsed
but we who sent you will see you take a
hundred thousand of our years to do that
and so this is not a realist you come
back we would have all long forgotten
about you that's if civilization is
still here so none of these drives solve
the interstellar travel problem relative
to a human lifespan if we lived a
million years as individuals sure
who cares if it takes a thousand years
to get somewhere that's one one
thousandth of your life sure if it's a
really interesting place what's going to
so what we really need is wormholes
wormholes just you open a door here and
on the other side of the door on the
back side you're in another part of the
galaxy
by the way viewers of this program
probably read more books than see movies
but there's a movie called Monsters Inc
the animated kids film there's a lot of
good adult humor in it too but so these
are monsters that work at a factory
these are monsters whose sole job in
life is to scare little children good so
of course why else would be a monster so
they work in this factory and this
factory makes doors doors and they have
the door there's nothing on it's just a
door they open the door and go through
it and it is the door of a child's
closet in the kids bedroom and so they
emerge from the kid's closet to then
scare the child then they go back
through the door and they're back at the
factory
that's a wormhole they didn't say that
in the movie but that's a wormhole
that's how a wormhole would work would
work would work yes and I tried to be
clever at one time I would like I was in
Charlotte Airport I had to go from a big
plane to a little plane and I swear I
want five miles in the air is probably
like just a mile but it felt impossibly
long and I tweet
try to be clever and I say I can't wait
till we have wormholes then that way all
Gates can just be adjacent to one
another gate 400 is just the other side
of the door gate number one someone
tweeted back dr. Tyson if we have
wormholes then you won't need airports
well ice it busted you got it so yes
that's that's so not proven what
wormholes it works on paper yeah but we
don't know how to make one or keep one
open because they'll have a tendency to
want to collapse yeah we just work some
science fiction that's the best place we
can invoke a wormhole but until then
we're going to be pretty much earthbound
if we left right now it would take us
nine months to get to Mars no no you
can't leave right now you have to leave
when Mars and Earth are properly aligned
so so just to remind people if you see
Mars in the sky and they start traveling
to it but no no you you have to travel
to where Mars will be when you get there
so it's a matching of trajectories that
matters here and so it's what we call
the minimum energy trajectory so it's
one where you burn your engines and then
you shut them off then you coast to Mars
until Mars pulls you into its
gravitational influence and then you
fall towards Mars that takes about nine
months but if you run your engines the
whole time which we can't do yet because
we don't know how we don't have enough
fuel if we have filling stations along
the way you could do this you fill up
burn your engines and then you're
accelerating to Mars by the way that
will give you gravity artificial gravity
inside the ship if the ship is
accelerating and then but to slow down
you have to turn the ship around and
then accelerate to slow down and but
anyhow if you do that you get to Mars in
weeks a few weeks but it'll take a
boatload of fuel to do that but if fuel
is cheap then why not just need filling
stations Lewis San Mateo California
you're on book TV with Neil deGrasse
Tyson yes I'm in the Bay Area there's
show with the Deepak Chopra right now
but them I'm choosing a mr. Tyson
instead I had a question about them okay
thank you I've done what I think of when
asked about human potential instead and
oh actually the thwarting of the
knowledge from a political forces like
Clinton's right now there's a I think a
woman astrophysicist in Hawaii who wants
to they know exactly what they want to
look for and they want to build a
telescope they're the largest one in the
world on the biggest mountain it would
be perfect except for some American I'm
sorry
Native Hawaiians who consider it sacred
so can't do it and so I guess thought to
build in the Canaries canary islands are
still dating um and I was just thinking
another example would be in terms of
particle physics they were supposed to
be a super collider built in Texas in
the late 80s and early 90s which would
dwarf the UM the one that's in Europe
right now the the one that's the largest
one in the world and because of the
success of Republicans saying that we
can't build it and pay for it to get pay
for wars that they can't pay for you
know science so just one thing you know
cuz it's just to me like at this point
we probably would have figured out those
matter right now maybe be on our way to
understanding dark energy and even
something unless you've covered a lot of
topics here and we'll get it we'll get a
response in a second do you work in
science in any way no I wish I'm I'm
unemployed but I'm not selling my Leslie
we need you be i universal basic income
but uh I just try to Kim to get some
books in the library from lecture on
Carol or Billy or some books but that
sort of constant change all right
Melissa thank you very much dr. Tyson
anything they'd like to say to him yeah
thanks for those questions and I think
books have always been the great portal
to to other places and other ways of
thinking
so happy to hear that you are so in that
whatever is your life's trajectory in
this moment books are giving you other
things to think about and look and Sean
Cal the writes great physics books there
- Sean Carroll's by the way there's a
think there's a science writer biologist
and then there's a physicist I assume
you meant - physicist when when when you
mentioned Sean Carroll but you might
have met the other one but I do want to
the so the on Mauna Kea in Hawaii is the
most perfect spot on Earth's surface to
have a telescope it is at 14,000 feet
above all moisture that could interfere
with review between you and the universe
airflow from the ocean across the
mountain is what we call laminar instead
of turbulent so that the images that you
get through the telescopes are sharp
rather than blurry so in recent years
there has been resistance to adding more
telescopes to the mountain top and
resistance that's come about from native
Native Hawaiians who who value the
mountain as a sacred place and so if
we're in a culture that respects
cultures as much or if not more than
science then you will get occasions
where you want to build something
technological that conflicts with a a
religious or cultural or spiritual or
sociological value and so you don't and
then you build it somewhere else this
happens so so these are choices a
country makes what was manifest here is
that if there's a telescope that was
going to be in Hawaiian is now in the
Canary Islands which is Spain and we
were going to have a particle
accelerator but then the next particle
accelerator to do what ours was going to
do because it got as budget zero is now
in Switzerland it simply means we will
lose the leadership in those areas and
others to come as long as that continues
that's just the
reality of this and the interesting one
of the many interesting things about
science is that it is science is not a
national thing in effect it's not it's
not anybody's national thing these are
objective truths being explored in the
objective universe so if the United
States doesn't do it that doesn't mean
no one else will other nations will rise
up for example the largest telescope in
the world today which focuses on radio
tell us it used what used to be the
artists ebo telescope in Puerto Rico
largest dish in the world in fact many
movie scenes are filmed including
several important ones from Carl Sagan's
film contact now the largest radio
telescope in the world is in China so
that if aliens who are sending signals
to us and we have to find it out of the
din of cosmic radio noise the Chinese
will be the first to communicate with
aliens not the Americans and so this
will just continue it's one of the signs
that the United States is sort of fading
on the world technological state there
are many but these are part of them if
you do not think science matters then in
the future you will be buying products
innovated elsewhere and your economic
health and stability you could still be
a functioning country but you're not
gonna be leading the world in anything
that will be shaping tomorrow's
civilization
Steve Anaheim California please go ahead
Steve Anaheim one more time right I
apologize dr. Tyson Steve is not there
but he brought up Carl Sagan what's what
was your relationship with him how did
you get to know it wasn't you know I
think the press occasionally overstates
what the relationship was I met him when
I was 17 just an anonymous high school
kid but what was remarkable about that
that he was already famous though he had
not yet done cosmos but he was already
famous had been on Johnny Carson The
Tonight Show multiple times
cover stories in Parade magazine he was
already well-known and I'd applied to
Cornell where he was on the faculty and
unknown to me that admissions office
sent my application to him to get his
comment in reaction my application was
dripping with the universe at the time
because I'd known since age 9 that this
is what I wanted to do he then sent me a
personal letter inviting me to tour the
campus and visit the lab so that I can
make an informed decision of where I
would attend and uh so yeah I said yes
so I got on the bus went from New York
City up to Ithaca New York this was in
December in the winter was cold and he
indeed met me outside the building took
me to the lab showed me the lab reached
behind him I never forget this we didn't
even have to look grabbed the book off
the shelf was one of his books and
signed it to me I just thought wow
that's badass
you don't mean have to work and whatever
your hand lands that's a book that
you've written and I have I still have
that book it was his book the cosmic
connection and it says to Neal future
astronomer carl and so then at the end
of the day he drives me back to the bus
station it begins to snow not an
uncommon thing in ithaca new york i
would later learn and then he says hmm
here's my home phone if the bus can't
get through just call you can spend the
night with my family and I'm thinking
I'm just like nobody from nowhere
and I I remember distinctly thinking if
I'm ever remotely as famous as Carl
Sagan then I will have a duty and
obligation to treat students with this
level of kindness and generosity that he
had exhibited with me and I didn't
ultimately attend Cornell but that was
an indelible moment in terms of how to
behave in the presence of others who
have ambitions on tracks that you have
laid or tracks that you are on so there
after I attended one of his talks he
gave a couple of public talks he blurbed
my second book I don't know if you have
it here that no you don't need to have a
hand up no not universe downtown at once
he called I came out in 1994 so I wrote
a letter to me I don't know if you
remember me I was a kid who did this but
even if not is my foot but it was my
second book um and so he read it wrote a
blurb and said Oh on page 17 I think you
have a typo is this and not that so
that's how you knew he actually did go
through the whole book so but that was
it until his widow and drill who was one
of the co-authors of the original cosmos
woman with huge talent in her own right
you know deeply insightful in fact for
me I would say she's one of the most
enlightened people I've ever met just in
terms of you ask her question and she'll
say something hey I never thought hey
hey that's good that's yeah keep talking
obviously here and listen did you just
talk for the next hour and and when you
meet someone like that it's that's a
special thing and so I was invited by
the estate that basically to host the
follow-on cosmos to the original and she
continued to co-author that with a
colleague of mine Steve Souter who also
co-author the original cosmos would call
so the two of them re-- teamed up for
this project and but other than that I
mean I had a few encounters with
with Carl maybe five but we weren't like
beer drinking buddies and hung out at
each other's houses it wasn't that
relationship and nor was it a mentorship
which you would presume you get that
with persistent one-on-one exchanges it
was more and let me pose a different
question do you actually have to be
close to someone for them to serve as a
mentor and I don't think you do you just
have to be aware of the examples that
they set and and what place they occupy
in society and if you're observant and
if they are successful at that then just
simply being aware and if you're
receptive to it simply being aware and
receptive can in its own way have them
serve as a mentor so I can think of it
as a mentor but if you use the word it
gives a different impression than what
people would be expecting of the word
how many day jobs do you have right now
ya know I claim only one day job
everything else was a night job so I'm a
director of New York City's Hayden
Planetarium there's another Hayden
Planetarium in Boston by the way which
is sort of buried within the Boston
Museum of Science so it doesn't have its
own sort of storefront in the name
Hayden it's at Saint Hayden money the
Hayden foundation well we were the fifth
planetarium in the United States but not
defense as famous as Hayden became in
New York it was the fifth planetarium
after Los Angeles Pittsburgh Chicago was
the first and there's another one I keep
forgetting and then came us so but all
that happened very quickly like within
10 years or so back in the 1920s and 30s
between 1930 and 1935 five planetariums
went on and so so Haim was alive when we
gave us the money but then the
foundation it was a financier so the
foundation existed and then they're
still active today they give monies to
programs that help kids after school
boost's they're sort of interest in what
it is to learn so so yeah so I'm
director the Hayden Planetarium at the
American Museum of Natural History but
also I mean I enjoy writing and a
perfect day for me is when the phone
doesn't ring there's nothing in my inbox
and I can just write I also want to get
back to the lab not something I've been
in much lately the proverbial lab so for
me it would be at the computer reducing
data from telescopes theorizing things
that can be tested just being a full up
scientist again I greatly missed that
it's now a very small fraction of the
time I invest in a week but I have have
a possibly delusional ambition that I'm
visible enough so other people want to
do exactly what I do and then they rise
up and then all the media starts
focusing on them and then I can sort of
back away and unnoticed and then I go to
the Bahamas and recover and then I sneak
into the lab and no.8 no one even knows
I'm missing I'm just gone and all these
other people on the landscape of science
communication that's my ideal future and
then I'll you'll never see me again
that's however delusional that plan is I
think about that all the time so there's
that there's I also when I'm invited I
give public talks although I can't honor
all and to take out about 200 a month
that's obviously an impossible number so
I need severe triage Whittle sat down
between zero and four and ideally we
snip them together so that it's a rapid
succession then I'd go back home so
there's that there's the universe
flinches I get a call from the press so
I'm a servant of the public's appetite
for knowledge of the universe and
science so and I live in New York City
as where we are right now so so it's
which is a major news gathering center
we you know CNN although that I think
the real headquarters are in Atlanta
they got a huge building here in New
York ABC CBS NBC all very close to the
Hayden Planetarium it's just a car ride
and also some of the may you know the
the comedic talk shows the The Daily
Show and
they're all here as well so there people
fly in and stay overnight to appear on
those shows and I just I'm home for
dinner
you know I say honey I'll be home in 20
minutes we finished taping and so that's
a lot of time and effort more than you
might think
because you'd like to see me on for the
five minutes in an evening news
interview for example but there's the
pre call and and you got to get there an
hour early and then you got to go into
makeup but I got to change and look
presentable and then so it takes out
it's like bites out of the day so what I
don't have that many other people might
have are long stretches of hours with
nothing comes in and there's a different
kind of thinking a different kind of
creativity that will manifest when you
have long stretches where you're not
tugged in 20 different directions
there's an old saying which I agree
entirely it goes if you want to be more
creative become less productive and how
do we define productivity I did with 50
emails today and I cooked the dinner and
I went shopping and I did it
look how productive I am yeah but did
you create anything did you have a new
idea did you invent something have you
reflected on reality if you have you had
you know there's a whole other thing
that the human brain does when given the
opportunity so I try to carve swathes of
time in the week for just that purpose
who is honey if you're saying honey I'll
be home for dinner
oh I don't actually say honey but that's
that's the the trope so my wife I would
we we bought Alice yes we both like
we're both foodies I would say not crazy
foodie foodies but we're we're we're in
the door in the front door but not in
the middle maybe we care about our
ingredients and what we now the food
tastes and one of my great regrets is
when we finally perfected a dish it
means we can no longer order it at a
restaurant because we make it better
than they do and going to a restaurant
is then no longer special and so I make
it really I
if I say so myself I make a really
excellent rack of lamb that I can no
longer order the restaurant because it's
not as good as mine and so that takes
that off the list and my roast chicken
is pretty good too so I don't order
chicken and restaurants anymore unless
it's some very fancy dish where the
chicken is just incidental to how fancy
it is and then you see the artisan ring
of the chef so we will go to a
restaurant it's like slightly more
expensive than it should be just to see
if something rises up in the menu that
that we observe so yes we care about
food and wine and well I also go to the
theater often I love a good corny
musical a good dramatic play and we have
the luxury to be able to do that as
residents of New York City as well of
course she's a PhD in math yeah she has
a PhD in mathematical physics actually
Richard Springdale Arkansas you have
been very patient you are on with
astrophysicist and author Neil deGrasse
Tyson on book TV hello uh gosh it's a
pleasure to speak with you sir
my question is in around the 4th century
BC there was a great named Hipparchus he
discovered something called precession
now for all those climate alarmists out
there and I don't want to be political I
want to be scientific would you please
explain precession and the effect it has
on this planet sure so parkus thank you
for the question Hipparcos was a
brilliant I mean I just I just imagine
what he'd be discovering today if he
sort of woke up in the 21st century
world and you show him all these tools
we have of science and of course he had
hardly any tools yet is just a brilliant
brain of his and so he so here's
procession is we have our earth and well
the multiple processions anything that
rotates or revolves will generally
process a procession is if you have like
sort of an elliptical orbit an oval
orbit around the Sun and here's the
planet sort of repeating that over time
the shape of that oval will turn even
though the planet is continually
orbiting the shape will move around the
center object that it's turning so that
would be the precession of your orbit
Earth spins on our axis and we point off
in one direction the direction where the
North Pole is with it with Polaris is
the North Star however we not we don't
we're not fixed in space doing that we
actually wobbled and we execute one full
wobble in 26,000 years okay so for
example 13,000 years from now our axis
will not be pointing towards the North
Star it will be pointing towards a
different object over here if there even
happens to be one so this is the
procession of Earth's rotation and the
way this manifests is on the night sky
we call it what's called the precession
of the equinoxes so earth's equator
projected onto the sky actually drifts
across the constellations over 26,000
years so what this means is the first
point of Aries as an astrologer will
tell you which says the Sun is entering
the constellation Aries on March 21st
that is the declaration of the first
point of Aries and beginning March 21st
if you're born in the next 30 days
the astrologer will say you are Aries
because the Sun is in front of the stars
or that constellation in the day people
didn't know about distance so they said
the Sun was moving through the
constellation but of course the Sun is
right in front of us plus the Sun is not
really moving at all it's not going
around but they didn't know this back
when they laid all this out
a asserting that the universe is
controlling your life so this first
point of Aries actually drifts and it's
been about 2,000 years since this was
laid out and the first point of Aries
was identified and so if you now look at
maps and ask what is the Sun doing when
it is when it's March 21st
it is not entering Aries it is an entire
constellation shifted from that because
2,000 years is about 1/12 of 26,000
years a little less it's a whole
constellation off so when you go to your
horoscope if you do this and you say I'm
a Libra or I'm a Scorpio I'm a this and
it tells you what you should be thinking
or doing the name of your astrological
sign actually has no correspondence to
what's going on in today's sky it is a
holdover from what people used to think
2,000 years ago and is a free country
read your horoscope if you want I'm not
even going to stop you go right ahead
I'm just I would expect that people
voting for people in charge would know
that you don't put someone who thinks
the universe of influencing their life
in charge of other people who know that
it isn't from your most recent book
astrophysics for people in a hurry quote
some of the water you just drank pass
through the kidneys of Socrates Genghis
Khan and Joan of Arc got a question if
you could expound explanation oh I'm
trying to in that part of the book I try
to make sure in in astrophysics for
people in a hurry it's not a very big
book but if there's a lot in there and I
wanted to make sure every 10 pages or so
there was something they were to blow
your mind
that was weak Oz mcclee true but you got
to go what in fact I have to reread that
just to fully absorb the significance of
it so here's the point in this cup of
water there's there's water in here
there's water in here
there are more water molecules in this
cup of water then there are cups of
water in all the world's oceans that's
how small molecules are so what that
means is if I take this and toss it out
there's enough molecules in what I
tossed to enter every other possible cup
of water any one draws from the world's
water supply there's enough to scatter
to every possible cup of water in the
world so if I drink this it comes back
out of my body in some way or another
any one of a half-dozen ways so that
re-enters the environment goes to clouds
it goes to the stream goes to the oceans
and give it enough time it mixes
completely so Socrates drank a glass of
water it is a certainty it's essentially
a certainty that some molecules that
pass through his kidney within that
glass that you just drank and this is a
statement of the connectivity of life
and the community of our existence with
one another the interdependence of what
it is we do and how it is we behave it's
not only that by the same reasoning
there are more molecules of air in every
breath you draw then there are breaths
of air in all the Earth's atmosphere so
by the same calculation every breath you
take contains molecules that pass
through the lungs molecules of nitrogen
not the oxygen because that mixes back
with the trees but certainly the
nitrogen well most of the nitrogen
because there's a nitrogen cycle as well
but molecules would scatter quickly and
easily throughout the atmosphere some of
those molecules pass the lungs of
whatever your favorite historical
character Jesus
it would have passed through their lungs
and so you want to think of us as
separate and distinct from one another
or not connected to the world but we are
and for me when I think of those
fascinating ways is there something that
you studied or learn that you just can't
get your arms around yet Oh tons look up
that you just can't quite accept but
there's some things that you I never
expect to get my arms around either
because they're too big or they're too
weird and often when you say I got my
arms around this it implies that oh now
that makes sense but as I lead off the
book commenting that the universe is
under no obligation to make sense to any
of us I don't have as a requirement that
I can one day put my arms around it I
can just recognize that it's there and
accept it even if it just sounds
completely weird and so what you accept
it because the evidence shows that it's
true not because you have faith or
because you want it to be true because
you need it to be true it's because
observation and experiment verified
observation and experiment has
demonstrated the truth in that statement
dr. Tyson you tweet at Neil Tyson is
your Twitter handle several million
followers here is a tweet you sent out
on March 11 2016 I occasionally wonder
whether the entire universe is nothing
more than a snow globe on the living
room mantel of an alien is that a
late-night 2 meter so yeah occasionally
you wonder that that's all we you know
the universe is all we know it's our
entire existence and look at what we do
- I don't know if this is still a thing
to do when you have ant farms you ever
have an ant farm and a little bit of
sand here and there's a vessel in there
little tubes
they're the ants just doing their thing
and I don't know if they're happy or sad
or they're thinking about it but do they
know they're in an ant farm
do they have self-awareness does they
have any idea do bees know that you're
about to steal all their honey they have
a world where they are pollen are
pollinating plants and coming back and
making honey do they have any idea that
we created that world for them when it's
a bee farm any idea at all so we get to
do this because we are smarter than they
are so we can outsmart them and create
an environment which in which we think
they are happy and therefore they do
what it is they want
so we outsmart our pets okay we we feed
them and continue to feed them that
keeps them there and we provide for them
but there's like we do things that
because we're smarter than they are they
don't know the difference right so could
it be that everything we know and love
in this world is just for the
entertainment of an alien is that that's
so hard a thought to imagine I know you
don't want to think that we want to
think we are we have free will we want
to think that we we're in charge but are
we so yes that I don't remember what
time of day I think tweets our date
stamped and time stamps but I don't
remember when I might have goes to that
well this is an email from Michael
Nuttall in Gainesville Florida got a
question for Neil Tyson are we alone why
are there why are there any evidence
about UFOs why is how he phrased it so
well any evidence about UFOs why is
there so so this sounds like are we
alone on earth rather than are we alone
in the universe
the we're not likely alone in the
universe if you look at how common the
ingredients of life are
how common it is hydrogen and oxygen and
nitrogen and carbon we're made of this
stuff that's the foundations of organic
chemistry carbon-based life this stuff
is everywhere we look in the universe
and so whatever happened on earth it's
not likely to be rare or unique because
carbon chemistry on which life is based
is the most formal kind of chemistry
there is and carbon is abundant across
the universe so if there's life
somewhere else it's probably based on
carbon that's not a that's not a it is
it's an fascinating bias but it's not an
unjustified bias and so the universe has
been around fourteen billion years
plenty of time to evolve all manner of
creatures out there particularly
microorganisms we have no reason to not
think of microorganisms as aliens they
don't have to have built a ship there's
just a lien life on another planet now
have we been visited that's a different
question than whether we assert that
there's life elsewhere in the universe
but we have people looking for life in
the universe as well as not only any
kind of life but intelligent life it
would try to be clever about how we
conduct those experiments on earth what
the UFO community puts forth as evidence
is weak on a level that in any
scientific circle would be kicked out of
the lab room you have things like
eyewitness testimony this I'm sorry this
is not working okay
no I don't if you walk into a conference
and say this is true because I saw it
you'll get laughed off this just we're
not saying you didn't see it we're
simply saying that you cannot present
that as evidence for something that you
want all
okay so so eyewitness testimony is not
something that's valued in scientific
circles I don't care what it is you're
looking at and especially if it's
something that would be truly
extraordinary like visitation by aliens
I need more than your eyewitness
testimony I don't trust your eyewitness
testimony if you told me the moon rose
yesterday okay I I need better data than
that I probably would trust that because
it's not extraordinary but on that level
but as your claim gets more and more
extraordinary the less the less
confidence I'm going to place in your
data taking system that involves your
eyes and brain it is why in science we
invent methods and tools of measurement
to replace our senses because we know
how feeble they are how
non-representational they are of reality
psychologists have known as ever since
they have been psychology in science
we've known it ever since we've seen the
effects of this influence data okay so
now now you take a picture or something
that you don't understand
that's better than eyes all right now
you have pictures or video that's better
okay so what is well it's unidentified
right that's what they use stands for
unidentified we don't know what it is
it's a mystery okay good what do you
only do about it
okay so my point here is if you've seen
a UFO do you just remind yourself with a
U stands for unidentified once you say I
just saw a UFO it really should just be
a period at the end of that sentence but
what typically happens is people keep
talking and they say I don't know what
it is therefore it must have been an
intelligent alien visiting from outer
space coming to earth to observe us but
wait a minute you just said you didn't
know what it is because it was
unidentified now you're telling me what
it must be the fact that you not
admitted that you did not know what you
were looking at we Clues all
the rest of this sentence that just came
out of your mouth okay
I'm not going to stop you from trying to
find the aliens I'd love to meet some
aliens but I have such low confidence in
your claims that they're aliens that I
will not be investing any of my time but
I'm glad you are go right ahead
and the day you find an alien I need
something better than your video camera
showing that it's unidentified and I
need something better than your
eyewitness testimony
ideally in fact bring the alien alright
you're good to go
I'm not going to stop you from doing
that a B everybody has a video camera
today everybody
where are the flooded YouTube postings
of people's experiences inside of flying
saucers shaking hands with the aliens
where is that we have video of extremely
rare phenomena now because everybody has
a video camera we have video of buses
tumbling in tornadoes there was a day
where you wouldn't say oh my god said
Buster's about to tumble let me go home
and get my shoulder mounted video camera
so I can film this no you're getting
your ass out of there when you see this
happen everybody has a video camera so
you
we have rare surveillance footage of
things okay if you've been abducted and
you had an encounter with an alien give
me some good video of it
and get some other people to get video
over to then we've got we're good I got
it but as long as it's unidentified to
you um
I don't have I made myself clear and
I've done this and by the way I have
very high experience looking at the
night sky and the day sky okay and
knowing what can happen in the night sky
and in the day sky I have seen things
which without this extra background that
I have I would have easily reported as a
UFO to the police department I know this
but because I've studied phenomenon of
the sky I could identify it here are
clouds that build above mountaintops
that take circular form that a very high
altitude if the amount is high the cloud
is even higher you're called orographic
clouds and some summer called lenticular
clouds but these clouds are very high up
they can have perfectly cylindrical
shape now watch what happens the Sun
sets you at the bottom of the mountain
the Sun sets for you it hasn't yet set
for those high altitudes because they
can see beyond your horizon so the Sun
is still there for them it gets dark for
you and the cloud is lit by sunset
colors orange red and it's vibrant and
it's circular and it looks for all the
world like the mothership just came and
docked over the mountaintop if you are
susceptible to wanting this to be true
then that for all the world is the
mothership where as to me it's a cloud
that forms naturally over mountaintops
when hot air goes up and cools abruptly
and water condenses out of it so and
then that people say this is a good eye
witness this person is a brigadier
general is the person who's the eye
witness human that's all that matters
you're no less to set no more
susceptible though less susceptible than
anybody else I don't care what your
title is I don't care if you're a
military pilot it doesn't matter I don't
care you're human you got to do better
than that oh and if you get abducted I
tell this to people if you get abducted
and it poking you poking your gonads as
of course all aliens do we've been told
telly telly Hey look over there and
there's snap something off the off the
shelf okay just do that okay and then go
back to the then we then when they let
you out you pull it you say look what
I've stolen from this from the alien
spacecraft an alien coaster or an
ashtray we can then take this to the lab
and see if it is of alien manufacture
okay and if the alien came here on a
spaceship from across the gaps of space
anything you pull off the shelf is going
to be interesting still waiting for that
to happen every guest we have on
in-depth we ask who are they reading
what are some of their career influences
things like this these are the answers
that we got from Neil deGrasse Tyson
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
Oh
[Music]
this is Henrietta Leavitt who was
looking at we're going to get to these
magnificent images who was looking at
images taken from South America because
the whole sky had to be covered there
was a second observatory built in Peru
to photograph the stars of the southern
hemisphere and she was looking at images
of the Magellanic Clouds
and she discovered a couple thousand
variable stars and made a fundamental
discovery about the pattern of variation
that the stars that took the longest
time to go through their cycles tended
to be the brightest stars and she
figured all of the stars she was looking
at were roughly the same distance away
so the ones that look bright a really
were brighter and that observation led
to the first usable yardstick for
measuring what we would call now
galactic distances and intergalactic
distances in space and her work enabled
the size of the Milky Way to be
determined and maybe getting ahead of
the slides here but also where I'll
figure out this that the Milky Way was
not the only galaxy in the universe that
the universe in fact consisted of
multiple galaxies galaxies so it would
be fair to say that at that time they
weren't sure if the universe was maybe
just a few hundred thousand light years
across and maybe that was it that was it
the shape of the universe like this led
to us looking at you know what geometry
of globular clusters and spiral galaxies
and then to place ourselves within that
geometry you can watch this and other
programs online at book TV org
here's a look at some books being
published this week former Secretary of
State Condoleezza Rice examines global
struggles for independence in democracy
Pulitzer prize-winning author David
Garrow explores the pre presidential
life of Barack Obama in rising star Pat
Buchanan former speechwriter and senior
advisor to President Richard Nixon
offers an inside look at the Nixon
administration in Nixon's White House
wars journalist Thomas olifant and
Curtis Wilkie were called john f
kennedy's presidential campaign in the
road to camelot also being published
this week university of pittsburgh
british history professor Holger hook
looks at the war crimes committed by the
british and continental armies during
the Revolutionary War in scars of
independence Eva Dylan reports on her
father's career as an American
intelligence officer and his
relationship with the CIA's top Soviet
double agent in spies in the family
Sally Motte Freeman shares the story of
two u.s. naval man's efforts to find
their youngest brother who is listed as
missing in action in the Philippines
during World War two in the Jersey
brothers and Rachel Pearson a resident
physician offers her thoughts on the
American health care system through her
own experiences in no apparent distress
look for these titles in bookstores is
coming week and watch for many of the
authors in the near future on book TV on
c-span too
dr. Neil deGrasse Tyson we asked you
your favorite books your influences and
what you're currently reading we just
showed that to our audience but you sent
us extra notes instead of just titles
you you gave some explanations including
on the day you were born you say is one
of your favorite books by Deborah Fraser
look children's books yeah it's a book
that if I knew how to write a children's
book it's a book that I would have
written but I didn't have I don't have
that talent that she did it's a it's a
very simple and beautiful account of all
the things that are going on in nature
in any given day of the year but you get
to read it to the to a child it's a way
for a child to be exposed to all the
things that nature does in this world
what earth does is a planet in orbit
around the Sun what a whale is doing in
the ocean what the Arctic Terns are
doing what so it's a it's a walk through
nature as so it's not that has nothing
to do with the Baker or the politician
or those are other things that are
happening on the day you were born but
nature is using nature is the is the is
what the person to whom is the child to
whom you're reading a story it is being
exposed and so I just think it's
beautiful and I even like I get
misty-eyed when I read it just it's just
so beautiful its nature brought to life
for someone who can't read yet on the
day you were born the book you're
currently reading science and humanism
by Erwin Schroedinger you call it a
mid-century assessment of the role and
value of science in guiding the progress
of civilization yeah I'd like reading
through the history of how people
thought especially as it may have been
influenced by the the politics or
culture of the time nineteen fifty is
sort of the dawn of the Cold War and
it's
because obviously it's before the wall
went up but it's still we're feeling the
aftermath of the Second World War the
divide of the world the world's powers
and this is a scientist who was around
and lived through it made seminal
contributions to quantum physics and
decided to write a little bit for the
public and that's not that's not his
first book for the but he had several
books that he's written for the public
one of them is just what his life and
he's talking about how physics manifests
in biology and these are short books but
a friend of mine gave it to me I saw it
on a shelf so I didn't know if showed
and you wrote this I say you want to
borrow it so that happens to be right on
my bookshelf at this moment 202 is the
area code if you want to participate in
our conversation with Neil deGrasse
Tyson this afternoon 7 4 8 8200 if you
live in the east and central time zone
seven four eight eight two zero one for
those of you in the mountain in Pacific
time zones will also cycle through our
social media addresses so that you can
contact us that way if you can't get
through on the phone lines we've got
about 50 minutes left with our guest
this afternoon and Heather in
Jacksonville Florida you have been very
patient please go ahead
hi there good afternoon Eric an honor to
speak with you I have a question about
your education I just finished my
bachelor's degree a little under two
weeks ago in communication and I'm
trying to figure out you are a graduate
degree thank you a little figure out
Chris knew that this degree or should I
go back and it'll for you too because I
actually like engineering physics so how
did you figure out if you wanted to
pursue an advanced degree and how in the
world did you end up paying for it and
yes I am taking books
okay well so this is a great questions
so so advanced degrees in especially in
academic subjects as opposed to medical
doctor law school that sort of thing
when I think of it academic subjects I
think you have to really really love the
subject all right whereas in medical
school you don't have to love medical
school to know that at the end
you want to be a medical doctor because
you have friends who are medical doctors
and no and or an attorney to enter
academic graduate school you have to
really really love it because you're not
going to get much money and at the while
you're in school and when you get out of
school you're not going to get much
money and the rewards are the act of
pursuing previously undiscovered truths
in any field could be English literature
or history or art or if it's academic
and in my in the sciences so and because
also things will not always go as you
want them and in the sciences for
example you could be in a lab and you
design the experiment and nothing works
well you don't get the result you
expected and you don't get a result
worth publishing you have to start again
and it's two years of your life if all
of what I just said
is a chore if you're saying no I don't
want to be in that situation then no
stay away but if in your life you have
learned to love the questions themselves
without regard to whether you asking a
question in a designing experiment to
answer leads to an answer then this is
that life so I it's a and by the way as
an academic if you get a faculty
position or in some case you can be
hired by corporations it's a decent
living you're not going to be the
wealthiest person on the block but
you'll have a car in a house and a
family and all you know there no there
no unhappy academics for the absence of
money ok so there's that part you say
how do I pay for it well in my field we
also worked as a teaching assistant
which participates in the teaching
Enterprise that the school undergoes so
that was worth a salary not very much
money
many people have roommates but that's a
flow of money after that it's still not
all that much but 20 but it's more and
if you went into debt in college what
you're doing what you love then
we're talking about the happiness of
your life here so so what if you're in
debt that's a kind of contrary in view
that most people have the content to
most people but my point is if you get
to do what you love and that and some
debt becomes associated with it then you
pay down the debt the debt takes you ten
years like so what 15 years so what we
all willingly walk into 30-year
mortgages when we buy a house supposed
to nope you're going into debt don't buy
a house you're going into debt but
though so how do we justify it we say
well the real estate value will be
higher at the end so this is an
investment that's what we tell ourselves
and for a lot of the time that's true
they're obviously important exceptions
to that especially in 2008 but all right
let's look at your education as an
investment we are now investing in your
enlightenment and your future happiness
shouldn't that be worth at least
carrying some debts such as the kind of
debt you'd be carrying in a home
mortgage so I I was never afraid of
death debt and I was in debt from
college and some in graduate school like
I said I got some payment in graduate
school so I didn't pay off my college
debt for when would it have been fifteen
years later and that's my salary kept
going up and I'm not talking about a lot
of money I'm just talking about going up
from a student money to like regular
person money all of a sudden the debt
that I've accumulated so many years
earlier looked smaller and smaller it's
because I was wielding more and more
money and so oh they need $1,000 I've
never paying $10 a month to start off
paying that debt I got my first job I
could pay $50 a month then I could pay
$100 a month and so yeah I'm I was
investing in myself and my future so
that's my answer and as they say if you
pick a subject to study
that you're in love with then you'll
never be working for the rest of your
life you'll just be having fun
Neil deGrasse Tyson's 2000 book the sky
is not the limit essentially is
autobiography in many ways a memoir
memoir Harvard University of Texas and
Columbia and I think the favorite
sentence in that book
let's read it for our viewers to set
one's genitals on fire seem more like
the absence of a creative solution to
money problems rather than a need to
dance was that a question look if you
want to expound on that that would be
fine everyone could just move on not
explain um yes so in high school in
college I was I was very athletic in
high school I was captain of my school's
wrestling team and in college I I
continued to wrestle I also rode but my
first love was wrestling and I also was
a performing member of two different
dance companies and because I also liked
not only being strong and limber but
also graceful flexible and graceful and
dance is that if it's nothing else and
so I just enjoyed what it could do and
be for my body and in graduate school I
continued to wrestle and row and dance
when I really shouldn't have been I mean
I should have been I should have never
left the lab but I continued this I
started graduate school in Texas where I
met my wife who the woman who would be
my wife and but before all of that I had
my fellow dancers and they here my money
problems and they said oh why don't you
dance with us we after hours we danced
at this strip club for women and and I
was like really buff at the time and I
could do a full split I could do things
that a stripper might do under all of
those situations that they described so
I said wow you know because I was really
struggling it wasn't
I probably would not have struggled as
much I know I would not have struggled
as much if I'd had a roommate but I
wanted to live alone I'd spent four
years in college with a roommate so that
increased my expenses and so a house so
they invited me down just to check it
out and I saw them come out within his
bestest line jock strap that had been
set on to fire had been ignited and they
were shaking their hips to the Jerry Lee
Lewis has great balls of fire
so in that instant I said maybe I should
be a math tutor I am embarrassed that
that solution did not occur to me
earlier because of course I can tutor
math I am a major to physics we know
math and physics so and ever and a math
tutor is method you need that anywhere
everybody needs a math tutor right so so
from then on I I tutored math for some a
few dollars an hour and that was fine
and it it may enable me to make my ends
meet Neil deGrasse Tyson is our guest
and Chris is calling in from Goldsboro
North Carolina Chris you're on book TV
thank you it was great seeing you
earlier today on am joy as well with dr.
Tyson oh thank you thank you
as well see it was great I always try to
catch moments where you're on TV um
about there both of these are live so I
went from that studio God in the car
came here and now I'm in this to do so
okay I know I knew you was in New York
because you had to go from one player
instead of I was just like okay he went
that way awfully quick oh no actually I
could have a wormhole but don't tell
anybody all right fine fine they say I
had things too so my first question is
was what I've seen on how to get on the
series on the Science Channel called how
the universe works um it was it was one
of those segments dealing with black
holes my question is all
was a feature that they discussed that
that was a possibility and involved the
speed of matter excelling faster than
right within this region of the black
hole because of the force of gravity my
question relates to if these conditions
were met outside of a black hole and say
Francis it happened near a planet or a
solar system will be the aftermath or
the effects of such a event occur today
thank you Chris yes so if I understand
your question you're talking about
somehow accelerating mass to the speed
of light or then beyond the speed of
light and what effect would that have on
its environment I think that was the
question so first of all yeah and
whether that's feasible I'm Kaila there
is no known way experimentally and
theoretically to accelerate a material
body to the speed of light and beyond it
you can get close to it but you're not
reaching the speed of light and that's
just it so we joke that the speed of
light is not just a good idea it's the
law
and it's not a matter of we haven't
invented a way to do it yet which was
the case with the the sound barrier
okay now consider that anyone who said
will never go faster than sound ever
well except that the tip of a bullwhip
that cracked that you hear it's moving
faster than sound not only that we had
guns at the time with a bullet emerge
from the barrel faster than sound so for
anyone to say man will never go faster
than sound they just did no no just
because you don't know how doesn't mean
we never will okay it is different with
regard to light this is not an
engineering limit it is a physical limit
of nature and like I said we've never
seen it we've tried and it's never
worked and theoretically it's not
possible
okay now that doesn't prevent something
I'm going to take the question beyond
that step that doesn't prevent something
from existing faster than light
we've hypothesized about such objects
you can't pass through the speed of
light but you can exist on the other
side of this and if you do then you move
backwards through time and and we
hypothesize a particle that does this we
call it the tachyon from the Greek root
a Chios meaning fast so a tachometer is
also a word that draws from that route
so so that would be really cool if
tachyons existed in this world people
have proposed experiments for how to
detect them and we've never found them
so just because it's okay in the
equation doesn't mean Nature has to
abide by that possibility so the fun
part about tachyons is let's say that I
see that you you're walking down the
corridor and you slip on a banana peel
and fall and I say oh let me prevent
that because I can send him a text to
warn him about the banana peel okay so
before he gets there because the Tachyon
will go back in time and reach you so I
send a message and I say watch out for
the banana peel and I send off the text
ten seconds before you get to the banana
peel you get a text and what do you do
when you get a text you reach in your
pocket you pull out your smartphone you
start reading it while you are weaving
my text that says watch out for the
banana peel you slip on the banana peel
but you would have you would not have
slipped on it if I did distract you with
the text that told you to look out for
the banana peel you would have just been
walking down the corridor so that's an
interesting case where the act of trying
to interfere with the past created the
very thing you try to interfere with and
so there's still a lot more thinking we
need to do on the frontier of
time-travel but that's an example of
something where an event may always be
happening exactly that way there's
nothing you can do to change it because
the act of trying to change it created
the event that you tried to change
Klein Observatory tweets in just saw on
book TV Neil Tyson lifts agnes clerk as
an influencer she chronicled the rise of
astrophysics in a remarkable set of
books yes so Agnes clerk I have I think
most of her books uh well I made to say
many of her books she wrote in the
nineteenth century which was a golden
age of astronomical discovery we don't
think of it that way because we have
much bigger telescopes today and you
know relativity and quantum physics all
those are 20th century discoveries but
the 19th century if you are around at
the time you would have been celebrating
how far science has come just keep in
mind if there's more science going on
than ever before that's a golden age for
you
never mind what happens later in that
moment you feel like you're at the top
of I have I have a book not of hers but
someone else's from 1890 that said I
wrote a book on the Sun in 1895 we've
just learned so much about the Sun I had
to I have to have a new edition and just
celebrating this like a little bit of
five years of discovery so what she did
was chronicle cosmic discovery not only
historically from the ancients to the
present but she has a book she was a
popularizer of
then modern astronomy this before
astronomy became today what we think of
as astrophysics and some of my books are
kind of doing just that I have a book
called the Pluto files chronicling the
demotion of Pluto if she were alive
today I think she would have written
that book so it's a I was delighted to
learn that there were people who cared
enough about science to then learn about
it and then share it with people who
have an interest in science who would
not otherwise be doing that work
themselves so that she's in math we say
she's an existence proof that this is an
interesting and useful thing to do Agnes
clerk it was probably pronounced Clark
but it's spelled CLE RK z ke yeah Clark
and
you familiar with Klein Observatory no
I'm not actually okay your book but if
you have a dome and it's also if you
call it an observatory it's an
observatory thanks so I'm delighted to
know there's an observatory I don't know
about that the more that the merrier
yeah in 2007 you wrote the book death by
black hole and you quote a gentleman
named Lord Kelvin who in 1901 said there
is nothing new to be discovered in
physics now yeah that was a boneheaded
thing to say and he had a certain
arrogance to him us sort of physicists
arrogance we're sort of in physics you
there's no real understanding of
chemistry without physics and there's no
real understanding of biology without
chemistry so physics I think is
justifiably considered the anchoring
subject of all the sciences so and
that's a justifiable claim the question
is whether gets to your ego as a
physicist and in his case that's one of
many examples where he's just kind of
saying things that that he really had no
business saying and 1901 within four
years special relativity would be
discovered by Albert Einstein but eight
years after that ten years after that
general theory of relativity would be
discovered four years after that all of
quantum physics would come down the down
the pipe so so yeah that's got to be the
most embarrassing statement ever uttered
by any scientist ever who's otherwise
respected and famous scientist and the
Kelvin temperature scale was named after
him by the way the sky is not the limit
came out in 2000 and dr. Neil deGrasse
Tyson wrote that the 20th century ended
without us knowing the composition of
90% of the matter in the universe yeah
so we have finer tunes numbers on that
so there's it's about 85% of so let me
say it's not that we don't know what 85%
of the matter is we don't know what 85%
of the gravity is that's a strictly
accurate statement we look around the
universe and we see stars and planets
moving
we add up all the gravity that should be
making that happen we get 15% that
includes everything we can think of and
dream up and know of black holes quite a
gas clouds stars moons planets all of
this added up is 15% of what is driving
this the gravity of the universe add to
that there's something that we call dark
energy which is responsible for the
acceleration of the universe and the
number is even higher so I can say with
some precision 95% of everything that is
driving the universe today which
includes what we call dark matter which
I referenced in that quote and what we
call dark energy those combined we can
measure their existence but we know
nothing about them they are driving 95%
of what is going on in this universe and
each of those gets a full chapter in
astrophysics for people in a hurry I'm
not going to let you get by unless you
hear no and and the loving if respecting
if not loving how we came to discover
the greatest mysteries in my field dark
matter and dark energy and astrophysics
for people in a hurry is his latest book
jess is calling in from anaheim
california go ahead Jess we're listening
hello hello hey it's I just wanna say
it's a great pleasure to talk to you I'm
a huge kind of reward but on my question
on you you've talked about this issue
with long distance space travel the the
importance of psychology and the
importance of gravity and so my
background psychology I was just curious
thinking about things like the synaptic
gap and stuff like that with gravity
because everything that we've ever done
every experiment every idea we've ever
had has had the effect of gravity on us
so if you were in a zero gravity
environment for a long time or say we
populate as a planet and evolve from
there well there's a different gravity
will that affect the transmission of
electrical and chemical signals in the
brain that's an excellent question
and I can say it's not lie
and experiments show that the answer is
in fact no for most things that matter
so consider the following when you're
standing up when you're standing up and
you have false right and you're you're
hungry or your love you hate whatever
normal sort of psycho-emotional thoughts
and gravity is pointing downwards so now
you just lay down now gravity is
pointing out of the side of your head
you have all those same thoughts you
you're you know it's somehow your brain
capacity is not deeply altered by this
okay so now you're still in a 1g
environment but the G is not pointing in
a completely different direction so you
look at the physiologically your veins
why does blood circulate at all does it
require gravity well not really your
blood circulates standing it circulates
horizontally it circulates at any angle
in between because your your vessels
pump on their own so why should we think
zero G notice on everything will just
stop not only that
electromagnetic forces are 10 to the
power of 40 times more powerful than
gravitational forces so all electrical
synaptic phenomenon going on in your
brain doesn't give a rat's ass about
gravity it is functioning completely
independent of it now chemically you
have chemic skem estreet on in a liquid
let's say well if the microbes are just
floating around they're kind of
neutrally buoyant they don't care about
gravity either they're floating in the
water suspended in the water so so so
that's a favorite living and the
chemistry of molecules doesn't care
either so it's why any of this works at
all under these very different
conditions now if you're in low gravity
and you grow up in low gravity that can
affect your
kilcher of course there's things
everything weighs less than it would on
earth now we bring you to earth that
could be bad you'll be you'll be a
weakling person here on earth unless you
lifted weights to get up to this what
here's what you do on Mars you
counterweight everything to weigh as
much for you on Mars as it would on
earth then when you come to earth
everything weighs the same as you
remember that's the kind of thing you'd
have to do in fact the movie that came
out a few months ago the space between
us is about the first child ever born on
Mars and the child is raised there and
he wants to come back to earth and they
explore the medical problems he has but
among them none of them is is capacity
for thought this is a first
marquis Filippo is another longtime
c-span employee with two sons and this
is first time you know they don't send
them in for the politicians the kids
they just send them in for you but jack
is 14 years old
drew is 12 years old great age and
according to mark they've been having a
week long debate about mass that even
took place for a half-hour in the
grocery store jack 14 wants to know that
since there is matter and antimatter is
there anti-mass since there is the
existence of mass drew wants to know
what mass there was at the Big Bang and
what triggered it which we've covered a
little bit but right great question so
it's not obvious on first pass that
antimatter shouldn't have anti mass I
mean think about it
it has anti everything else is the
opposite charge and in quantum physics
it has the opposite of other certain
quantum features that are not familiar
in our everyday lives but particles live
with this like spin and angular momentum
this sort of thing there's but the
simplest thing to ask is if an anti
particle has anti mass can that mean
would that mean
should that mean that it has
anti-gravity and this is an implicit
consequence of the question does it have
anti mass it turns out no it doesn't
have anti mass so nor does it have
anti-gravity and the equations of
gravity are such that it doesn't matter
what your mass is made of it will
attract you no matter what because your
mass actually drops out in the equations
and all that matters is how far away you
are for me to determine how much I'm
going to attract you to me so no there
is no negative mass in the original
equations when they were first seen it
showed up as an as a negative mass and
the big question is how do we interpret
this and it got interpreted as having
negative properties in all these other
regimes opposite properties justifying
the term antimatter now where did all
this come from matter and energy are
interchangeable
we did all the energy of the universe
come from it's a frontier of cosmic
research we got top people working on it
but otherwise we don't we don't know for
sure and like we said earlier it may be
embedded as part of a multiverse but
then you ask where the multiverse come
from so one of these that are talking so
Wilson so we don't know we don't know
but we know that it exists and we're
describing it ever since it came into
existence have you visited CERN no I've
not visited it's on my bucket list
though just I just like the largest
machine in the world is the this the
European Center for Nuclear Research and
I think that's how you parse out that
acronym they've got the largest particle
accelerator in the world the Large
Hadron Collider
that's what discovered the famous god
particle now one or two years ago so so
yeah it's on my list
Georg Eagle Colorado please go ahead
with your question or comment
an orange ice in Colorado
yeah dr. Doug mutation here promoter -
it's a pleasure to talk to you I have a
question there's always been interesting
to me
can we ever harness gravity and use it
for propulsion mmm
if there's that's a great question if
there is and you're right that's been on
people's minds forever if there's a way
to do it we have yet to figure it out
and let me flesh out that question and
imagine that we have some suitcase where
we can harness the force of gravity or
control the force of gravity so that we
can either increase it or reduce it so
there's still people to this day who
think that NASA has a room where you go
in and you're floating and that's the
zero gravity room but that's not the
case the closest we have to that is what
we call the neutral buoyancy tank which
is NASA YZ for a big swimming pool and
astronauts working on the Hubble
telescope and practicing spacewalks do
it submerged in that swimming pool it's
in Houston Texas Russia has a
counterpart to it in there for the Space
Center as well so because think if you
can turn off gravity right below the
launch pad of a rocket then that fuel
with the rocket is using oh my gosh the
acceleration it would give you if you
went away from zero jeans and from 1g
for example so no we just have not
figured out how to control gravity and
network in that way it's always as far
as you know been associated with a
concentration of mass or energy January
29th a tweet from Neil deGrasse Tyson
seems the world goes batshit crazy every
few decades just long enough to forget
the last time the world went batshit
crazy
yeah people reacted heavily to that what
I you know I know what do I mean by that
you know what the first world war
it's like oh my gosh what is this what
we call civilization
we're gassing we're digging trenches and
wholesale slaughter of other human
beings and then you know a few decades
later the Second World War
50 million people die fact you can run
the numbers on this a thousand people
per hour were killed in the Second World
War a thousand per hour and you look
today and there's like a maybe there's a
terrorist attack and a dozen people are
dead its headline news of the last
several days I'm glad it's headline news
but that tells me how far we've come
when a thousand people dying per day in
the during the Second World War was not
itself news
it was old land has taken more battle
we've won the battle or we we conquered
this one it is if the terms are not how
many people died the terms are what
political gain have we have we put into
play so what happens after that you know
a few years after that and there's like
Vietnam and you go further back and then
there's like civil war and the slavery
and I don't know I just felt compelled
to reflect on this wondering whether the
natural urge is to sink back into some
crazy behavior and then we have to react
to how crazy that is and slowly build
ourselves out of it just taking long
enough to slip back into it once again
so yeah for me it was a very it was a
sad tweet but I want people to reflect
on what has happened before so that
because we can look at the old day what
they didn't know what they were crazy
thinking this how could they think this
way what were they thinking well ask
yourself in 20 years what they'll be
saying about us I do
lot of the reading of the history of
science in the history of culture it
books printed in the day so you feel
what they're feeling not just a
recounting but look at the words they're
using and how they we look back at the
temperance movement and the banishing of
alcohol and so how did today that crazy
how could they have done that I if you
read op eds of the day and newspapers
and magazines and articles in the
Atlantic Monthly and then it is filled
with accounts of families that were torn
apart by the drunken husband who comes
home and and and and what Costas is to
society you just see the build-up it's
there and if you are alive back then you
there's no reason to think you would
have said no you shouldn't do this this
is stupid you just watch the wave go
take everybody with it
culminating in an amendment a
constitutional amendment we don't have
an Equal Rights Amendment who had an
amendment banishing the production sale
and consumption of alcohol outside of
church religious ceremonies and so what
will people in twenty years be reading
about today to say what were you guys
thinking once it's obvious can't you
please flew the tree the forest for the
trees I wonder so I think about this all
the time hence the tweet any
significance to the fact that it went
out January 29th a week after the
inaugural um I'm sure there was
something that week that was just people
just reacting I mean um it wasn't so
much the election but there's the
election plus the reaction to the
election plus the what he says about the
election and I mean the inauguration and
and I think it's just the total conduct
of everybody just at odds with one
another at war with one another and
killing one another saying things that
you can't imagine in a civilized world
you would
say to one another I was really just
reacting to that you've worked on
commissions for the past two presidents
correct I was on two White House
commissions under President Bush and
President George W Bush and under Obama
we had met several times but I was not
on a formal Advisory Committee to him
and right now under well towards the end
of Obama and now into the Trump
administration I serve on a board of the
Pentagon so I have these occasional
tours of duty when I'm called into
Washington I'm delighted to serve at
just as a citizen if I have expertise
and insight that can help governance I
would be irresponsible to decline such
an invitation so and of course it's
unpaid it's not they reimburse you no
food and whatever but it's otherwise
unpaid and so it's my civic duty because
they'll never pick me for for a jury
duty I'm o for three on that one so the
least I can do is help the federal
government make decisions when and where
they need to just a couple minutes left
with Neil deGrasse Tyson Thomas and
Tiffin Ohio you might be the last caller
go ahead hi Neil I really appreciate
your passion for science and you're
sharing it with us I have perhaps a
simple question in failure analysis and
forensic analysis you can often point to
the center of an explosion now the Big
Bang is sort of like an explosion can
astronomers point to the center of that
Big Bang and what would they get from
looking in that direction and looking
from other directions thank you yeah
it's a great thank you that's a great
question so the Big Bang explosion so
it's one thing to speak of an explosion
of like a fireworks display or a bomb
forensic ly and then analogize it to the
Big Bang but there's a limit to where
those analogies can take you and there's
a point where they fail so because the
Big Bang isn't is an explosion not only
in space but in time it's a four
dimensional explosion there is a center
to that explosion but you don't have
access to it the center to that
explosion was 14 billion years ago when
everything that exists today was in the
same place at the same time so you'd
have to so if you think of we go back
you might have heard of this analogy to
the surface of a balloon where we lose
one dimension just so we can describe it
we lose one real dimension so we can
describe it among ourselves in ways our
human brain is wired to see it so
imagine our universe as the surface of a
balloon and you draw a little spiral
galaxies' on it and as you inflate the
balloon the distance between all
galaxies grows that's precisely what's
going on in our universe but it grows
not because the galaxies are separating
from one another within the space it's
because the space itself is stretching
and this is as prescribed by Einstein's
general theory of relativity and our
experiments bear this out so here is the
universe now at this size but yesterday
it was a little smaller
yesterday it was a little smaller so if
you want to ask where is the center of
this surface that's like asking where is
the center of the surface of the earth
the question actually has no meaning you
know to not ask that because there isn't
it doesn't it's the wrong question given
the geometry of what's going on so but I
can say I can ask a different question
not where is the center of this universe
the surface of the sphere I can ask when
is the center of that universe and the
when is 14 billion years ago so the
timeline in a sense is this vectors
pointing straight out from the center
through the surface of the universe that
we live in and
as the bulb as a balloon gets smaller
and smaller you're going back and back
in time damn that is the center of that
explosion 14 billion years ago let's fit
Adrian and Memphis in hi Adrian hello
I'm in seventh grade I saw you in
Memphis and we'll meet you in st. Louis
my question is about black holes I want
to know what is in black holes why it is
there and how do you know it great
question and you should sound like
you're in college by the way but you're
in seventh grade okay that's it is hope
for the world so a black hole so I guess
if you're if you're in seventh grade you
would have been maybe four years old
when I published the book death by black
hole so in there there's a whole
discussion about black holes and also
how how they can kill you but what we
know is if you're standing on the
surface of the earth and you want to
escape earth unlike what your grandma
told you what goes up must come down
that's just false it's true for most
things but there's a speed with which
you can toss something so that it never
comes back ever to earth and we give a
word for that in physics we call it the
escape velocity for Earth and for Earth
that speed is seven miles per second
seven miles per second and when the
astronauts went to the moon they had to
travel nearly that speed so that they
wouldn't just fall back to earth when
they lit their engines and then turn
them off they need to have enough speed
to get to the point where the moon can
then pull them in away from the earth so
they traveled like six point eight miles
per second but any it's about seven
miles per second you can imagine if
Earth's gravity were stronger you would
need a higher escape velocity to leave
and never come back
that would make sense the Sun has a
higher escape velocity than Earth does
it has a stronger gravity at its surface
well let's continue this exercise did
something John Michell did a national
astronomer from way back
like a centuries ago he said suppose I
had a star that has such high gravity
that light traveling at the speed of
light is insufficient to escape if that
were the case the star would just darken
and contain all the light that it wanted
to generate and he called this a Dark
Star hypothesis all right and so this it
turns out to do the calculation
correctly requires Einstein's equations
not classical equations of Newton which
he used because Einstein's equations to
get the correct right answer but when
you do this you have what we call a
black hole and we we have examples of
black hole in the galaxy no you can't
see them directly because there's no
light coming from them as you would
suspect sometimes you can see distortion
of the fabric of space and time in their
vicinity so the star field behind them
gets distorted they uh make a left
instead of going straight in because you
don't want to get sucked into the black
hole drawn into its gravity but the most
common way we find black holes is when
they beat they fly stars and gas clouds
that come near them and it spirals down
gets hotter and hotter and hotter and
before it enters it radiates brightly in
ultraviolet and x-rays we have x-ray
telescopes as powerful as the Hubble
Space Telescope you've never heard of
them because it doesn't take the pretty
pictures that Hubble done
does we have x-ray telescopes in space
that finds and maps these black holes
across the galaxy so that when the day
we finally go space traveling you know
what to avoid dr. Tyson you have one
minute to answer this question from your
2012 book space chronicles Friday April
13th 2029 Oh what's going to happen so
it is a closed approach of an asteroid
called Apophis this is an asteroid we've
discovered its orbit crosses Earth's
orbit and sometimes it crosses very
closely and in fact April 13 2029 this
asteroid which is the size of the Rose
Bowl will come so close to Earth that it
will dip between our orbiting
communication satellites and us now
those are fightin words that's you know
these ones that go twice the earth-moon
distance four times that are we call
them close close calls but they're not
will just wave as it goes this one your
cut you're invading our space and it
turns out that this asteroid will not
have a trajectory that will then hit us
in 2036 there's a periodicity where we
are in the same place as it in our orbit
and so the big worry was at that time
will it actually hit us and the orbital
calculations are good enough now to say
that no it will not hit us on either of
those two days but there will be a close
approach and it will be banner headlines
when it does
well Jeffrey Dunham wonders whether
Earth's inhabitants should either be
worried or not worried about errant
asteroids yes one of several ways we
will most assuredly go extinct is it
that we discover too late and hack and
too late to do anything about it reminds
me of this comic it may have been in The
New Yorker there's one dinosaur lazily
leaning on a rock and the other one
comes up to and it says I'm saying now
is the time to build an asteroid defense
system at big dinosaurs just laying
there all lazy to just kicking back in
their Jurassic laziness so no I it's yes
we should have a defense system in place
at all times and we don't Neil deGrasse
Tyson has been our guest for the past
three hours his most recent book is
called astrophysics for people in a
hurry this is book TV on c-span too